This episode of Your Mom's house is brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Christina,
I mean let's do it.
Let's do it.
Hey.
Hey
space travel in a paper airplane.
Oh that's nice.
Bye.
I can't tell who it's by.
Coded Polecat Yup.
Okay.
All right.
And then everybody has a name that rolls off the tongue coated polecat.
Uh,
all right.
Here's um,
some shows that you can still get tickets to the late show in new haven on March
30th.
Does that income net account?
It is.
And uh,
there there's a few tickets.
I don't know how many will be available by the time this comes out,
but you can try to get them late show in Madison.
Wisconsin has picked up still some tickets if you want to try to get into that.
That's at the Orpheum April 11th,
the late show.
The early show is sold out late show in Milwaukee on the 12th you can try to get
tickets to and the late show in Nashville is the only thing left that we can
April 14th.
It is almost sold out and by the time this comes out it might be gone.
Um,
Bethlehem,
PA,
uh,
April 25th has a less than 200 tickets left.
And let's see,
you can go to the only show you can get to in Boston still is April 28th.
That is the late show.
April 28th and then I added a show a or May 1st in Portland,
Oregon.
If you want to try to go to that.
The April 2nd show in Portland is sold out April,
excuse me,
May 5th in Seattle is the only show left with tickets in Seattle.
All the others are sold out and uh,
you can go on down the line there.
Thompson gretta.com/tour.
You can see the tickets in May and June.
Um,
we are announcing a bunch of shows.
Uh,
we're going to make the announcement in April,
so it's going to be in about three weeks if you want to get tickets before
anybody else for the second half of the tour.
That includes all the Canadian dates,
a bunch of us dates,
some other international dates.
Sign up at my email,
a website.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash tour and there's a prompt and you put your email
in there and then we'll announce that shows first and you can,
you can jump on them before anybody else.
Okay.
Mommy.
Uh,
many apple to it's acme comedy club.
April four through six.
My early shows are sold out and those tickets are going really fast,
so hop on it.
Uh,
Tempe,
Tempe Improv May 10th and 11th June 1st I will May 31st through June 1st Burbay
California sperm bank at Flap Hairs Comedy Club June 20th through 22nd
Washington.
Dick come at the DC improv tickets at Christina p online.
Also,
if you're not aware,
if you're new to the program,
please check out my Netflix specials.
I have a mother inferior my hour and half hour.
The degenerates along with Joey Diaz.
Big Jay Oakerson Lee's a Trager.
I'm Shawmanee Shawmut.
So Monica is to Sanders.
Yamaneika Sanders.
Sorry guys.
Yep.
Try it out.
Christina piano line homes.
All right,
that's it,
right?
That's it.
Catch me outside.
Instagram.
The Christina p
the sadness.
Aw Man.
It was just,
he was just,
you know,
just to have the same America.
What's happening on the wrappers on this show are really influencing here.
Uh,
one other thing before we get started,
don't forget,
this is your last chance.
March 22nd.
That's a Friday,
10:00 PM the Hollywood improv has the great non coming Josh Potter,
they great cockroach comedian,
the cockroach comic at the Improv lab here in Hollywood.
Glorious,
Glamorous Hollywood,
California at the legendary Melrose Improv lab.
10:00 PM show,
Josh potters headlining.
I know he's bringing a Doug Mellard.
Oh my goodness.
And a couple other people are on the show.
Get tickets now.
Go to Josh potters page or just go to the Improv website.
Um,
and get tickets.
Man.
It's going to be a really great show.
That's that
as Regina has a lot of business,
it's a lot of business.
We did it.
Get into this show ready?
Oh Gosh.
I'm afraid to,
but are you a com slash
you hooked on,
Geez.
Are you a comp sissy?
Do you love watching a sub?
G is all over the place.
Okay,
Christina?
Yeah.
I had a couple people complain that the intro is too long.
They're going to do in making it longer.
No,
because I want to get to the fun.
I want to get to the show and then I have to wait for the whole song.
I'm upset,
but I think I'm going to make a longer,
no.
Yeah.
Are you a calm sissy and yes.
I love to watch myself Jessel over everything.
I kind of feel like every guy does.
Don't,
you know,
I mean,
it seems like it's pretty neat.
It is pretty neat.
Yeah.
It's like this spout that just goes off
the first time that happened to you where you like,
whoa.
Like,
did you know is going to happen come shots.
Yeah.
He did.
You know that that was going to happen to you when the first time he did that?
I'm trying to remember.
I mean,
you know what,
I,
um,
I always had a real distance on me,
so I was,
I was fascinated,
you know,
quantity and firepower,
but I'm saying the first time,
do you remember the first time I just came out?
Were you like,
well member,
Oh dude,
does that supposed to happen?
Oh yeah.
You're like,
oh my God.
Yeah.
I mean I remember if I can cite the first time like vividly,
that was the first time,
but I remember being like,
Oh shit,
this is a mess.
You know,
and,
and having to clean it up.
And I remember one time I was staying at a relative's house and you know when
you really,
you'd get so fired up when you're 1213 so like I got to jerk off.
So I went in the bathroom and I stood over the toilet and I jerked off and then
it shot over the back of the toilet.
So I thought I was going to go in and then it was like,
oh shit.
Some landed on some magazines when that like good ones like time and like better
homes and gardens.
I was like,
Oh fuck.
Those aren't the good magazine.
What I'm saying,
I wasn't jerking off on a playboy.
It was right.
You know,
it was like a new,
like mom's magazine,
like Shaw.
I love this shit so much.
Now back then.
Did you use your imagination because you're only,
you know,
I didn't,
he says yeah,
it was just,
and then did you wipe off the magazines or you just left it?
No,
no,
no.
You wipe it off,
hide all that stuff from your mom when you're that age because your mom's still
doing your laundry.
Yeah.
You know,
I used to do,
I used to jerk off into boxers and then I'll just throw those boxes under my
bed.
That's not a good strategy though.
I know they would just,
I just be a pile and then one day they'd just be gone.
Uh,
she was like,
I found your combined things that she proud.
Like my mom doesn't know a lot about that world know is what you did?
No,
I think she probably thought it was wet.
Like,
you know,
understood that there's wet dreams.
I don't think she thought
I was in there.
Like I'm cranking this thing out every night now.
I don't think so.
Can I tell you the grossest story ever told?
Yeah.
When I was in college there was a boy I knew about.
Who
you are,
not me.
I am definitely not who I listened to.
This though.
You're going to get very sick.
Everybody listening is can get very,
oh,
right now he would the GOC every night in his same pajama bottoms.
So he would wear the same Pajama bottoms night after night and he would just,
you know,
ah yeah.
Bus Nuts in those jammies and then,
oh wait,
wait,
no,
sorry.
I think he would use the same rag and then he put it and then he throw it to the
side of the bed.
Anyway,
he used the same thing over and over and I remember he left it there and then it
grew mushrooms.
Yeah,
it was so gross because we lived in England,
it was my year abroad and the climate in England is like,
you know,
cold and clammy.
And so it grew mushrooms because he was using like the same jizz rag every
night.
Everybody involved in this or something.
Yeah.
But he had the roommate I think discovered it and then we caught wind of it.
We heard about this kid.
She's jizzing into the same,
right.
The same.
I grew mushrooms.
Yeah.
Cause he left it by the side of his bed.
I'm going to fucking throw it.
I know I told you it was the grossest story ever told.
Are you proud of me?
Yeah.
It was pretty good.
Proud of my thought.
Yeah,
you should be proud of all slob.
Ugh.
God.
Do you love licking your own comp?
I don't know what somebody's doing it right now is as her.
It's your mom's.
This is what she does.
Your mom's friend.
She,
yeah.
Are you a little calm?
Hi.
Are you hooked down?
G is,
yeah.
You a come sissy.
Do you love what she gets?
Some [inaudible] all over the place?
Yes.
Do you just love the taste of net?
Are you addicted to cum shots?
Come excite you.
Are you a pro swallower taste the smell.
The texture of some hot coffee.
She's not playing any games.
No.
She went to hell right here.
Okay.
She had really been into our come gum idea.
I remember I used to have chewing up all the different guys,
like um,
like chewables or tidal wave and there would be in the metal thing.
I come different races.
A Peter?
Yeah,
he was an Asian Gum Asian guy.
Ralph.
Yeah.
Do you love cream pie?
Do you love licking your own comp?
Got It.
Thank you.
Wrap it up.
You crave your own taste and,
no,
I love the way I taste.
What about shoes?
Do you love the way you taste?
Do you love watching other stations?
Okay.
All right.
Wow.
Good morning.
She likes the way she tastes.
She likes her on her own.
Uh,
most people do.
Vads Jews.
Really?
I don't know.
I don't really do that to myself.
Do you really?
Do
you do it sometimes?
Cause at the end of her,
yeah.
Thank God.
Her whole vibe that,
does she have other stuff?
Um,
I mean she has a youtube channel called Kinky kid.
It's all kind of in this lane and isn't that lane all right.
Lord's work.
It's Christian Christian.
They allow this on youtube.
You're allowed to talk.
So
yeah,
I mean she's just talking about it.
You know,
she's not shoving anything up in her.
Can you do that?
Can you,
um,
can you like eat Jizz on Youtube?
I mean,
that's a,
it's a blurred line I think.
Yeah,
find out.
John,
you want to find out?
I do want to find out.
God,
Josh Oranges.
Yeah.
Should we stop down for a second now?
Now,
now how quickly can Joss Jizz
hold on.
We're going to switch places for a second.
Yeah.
This inquiring minds,
this is boring listener information.
Got The whole world is on bated breath.
Waiting for Josh has calming the whole world wants you to come,
Bro.
Everybody's asking.
Yeah.
How long does it take to make me come by myself?
I mean it depends on the scenario obviously,
but uh,
you know,
I could get it.
I could get it out pretty quick.
Probably name under the gun.
If there's a gun to my head though,
I don't know if I could,
it's not gun to your house.
Let's say I'm like,
Hey,
you know,
you haven't released in a few days for this purpose.
Like,
if you want me to taste my own comic could have it ready by the ad spots,
you know,
for the show yet.
Would you dictate your own changes?
I'd probably,
I think I accidentally have.
You know,
you were talking about your,
your velocity and how hard you've launched.
Yeah,
I've definitely like accidentally boot cocky myself in the past now.
So I've definitely probably tasted Modelo.
Covered my own face.
Yeah.
Lately I've laid on my back and just bathed in it.
The worst is when you get it in,
in your glasses because of the shame of cleaning your glasses.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
And the thing where you have a girl wear glasses or maybe she does cover the
glasses.
I do it with my own sometimes I've done it with my own glasses.
Yeah,
it's called specs appeal.
It's fun cause then I can't see either.
So it's like,
am I hitting the glasses?
I don't know.
I get to find out after.
Yeah.
That's cool.
So did you talk guys,
you can come inside ladies since we last spoke.
Not yet.
We're still doing research out there.
We're getting to the bottom of it.
You know,
every day's a new day and a new discovery.
So have this attitude.
How about your DM game?
Is it,
I don't know if you saw some tweets out.
Some emojis.
Yeah,
I went Emoji.
You took style,
the BDE that Ryan was talking about and I applied it and I think it's working.
I got a couple of nudies
to your colleagues policy here.
Where are those?
Nudie?
Oh yeah,
no,
they'll,
they'll be at the weekly recap.
Oh,
okay.
Good,
good,
good.
What were they good ones?
Some were good.
Yeah.
You know,
they were all there.
All at Paul.
Appreciate it.
I appreciate them.
Up and down.
Left naked chick is every naked chick.
Every,
let's be real here.
Well,
all I want you to do,
you know my fingers are crossed for you to finish and a nice lady.
I pray every day to the Lord above that.
Someday I can feel what it's like to just blast off inside of a woman.
I spoke to a doctor about the value.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
There was a doctor at my show and he was like,
yeah,
he needs to see someone like me and a therapist.
Oh,
together.
Two of them.
That's what he said.
Yeah.
You definitely need a therapist.
I think that's problem is emotional cycle.
That partially,
I'm assuming I,
I'm,
I'd,
I'd think there might be some trauma that there's something to,
to the audience.
I appreciate everyone's feedback on it.
Yes.
Everyone seems to have their theories.
Let me tell Ya.
He's got a lot of oh yeah.
These people who blow loads all the time have all kinds of advice.
Uh,
the one that they're like,
hey,
maybe you should get different glasses.
You could get a smoke show.
And that way,
these are not for show people.
These are,
I have to wear them.
I don't want to,
these aren't like my,
that's not going to help.
You know,
I thought maybe if I got better ones,
I could see the girl in more HD,
you know?
And then maybe that would help me come because maybe it's because it's blurry.
I think you need help.
We got to go to the doctor.
What kind of doctor were you speaking with?
Just that there was a urologist.
The urologist need a therapist.
Oh,
that's so much doctor stuff.
It is.
But you want to come last time you saw?
Yeah,
I know.
Boy.
Cockroaches on go to the door in the year 2019 guy.
Uh,
it would have been
eight years ago.
Mandated physical for a job.
Dude.
Can we get another physical going?
Yeah,
I'm scared to find out.
What's a good idea though?
Don't you feel like if I find out what's wrong then I,
then I'll die.
You know what I mean?
Like for the show though.
Okay,
that's true.
Yeah we can,
I'll put my fuck all that Hipaa Shit.
I'll put it all out there.
You could be having neuropathy issues and then in that case we can do math on
the show.
Boom.
I might have to have you film that elsewhere just for legal reasons.
An undisclosed location and then,
but then just make sure you get a high quality video.
Of course.
Yeah,
of course.
Um,
all right.
Well look,
I'm going to do is come soon enough,
you know,
we'll keep,
we'll keep it in the last job.
We'll get at it.
Thanks buddy.
And guys,
please don't send us the book.
Natural Harvest.
We've,
we've gotten the link many times.
Natural harvest is a book that's full of cum recipes where you can,
you know,
make cakes and things like we've got it.
Thank you.
Don't,
don't send me natural harvest.
Who keeps it a hundred?
Um,
Kay gene last night.
Ah,
we went to uh,
Brody Stevens Memorial.
Yes.
It was amazing.
It was beautiful as a many people probably saw it on periscope,
the periscope yesterday because he was the prince of periscope and um,
it was like a really awesome energy and celebration and remembrance of that guy.
I mean,
the amount of people that showed up.
Oh,
just wanted to pay respect or show love to them.
Yeah.
So many friends.
I had no idea he had celebrities.
Baseball players can lenient just Pete randos and um,
we all cried.
Everybody went from laughing to crying,
laughing to crying.
Yeah.
Jack Golf.
Very nice.
Okay.
You like the most amazing,
yes.
Back and forth speech like that where he was,
it was touching and heartfelt and then hilarious.
And then,
you know,
it was going,
it was back and forth and it was like,
there was like an emotional rollercoaster just to,
to be there.
Yeah.
But I will say,
you know,
Jeff Ross had some great lines which we'll get into,
but um,
but he made this great point that,
you know,
comedy is this receptacle for broken people and um,
I dunno,
it's nice to know that we have a community of broken toys and this show your
mom's house too.
I feel as nick is obviously an extension of,
you know,
the comedy club and the store and all that.
Yeah.
And that people belong,
you know,
we all belong together and it's sad when you're missing a piece though.
Brody was such a big piece of our,
yeah.
Our fat.
If it was very,
you know,
comforting to see so many people care.
It was.
Yes.
And we drank a lot and been Burton work a lot.
Burke drank so much,
so much.
I had a tip,
the waitress extra cause she,
Brett,
she brought so many beers.
Yeah,
I,
I did.
He had,
so at one point before we started,
he had six beers in front of them,
uh,
and a glass of wine and I was like,
just [inaudible] and then,
you know,
they brought a few others,
then we go to take a pee break and as we're coming back he's holding like he has
his hands like this and there's this bottles sticking out and he's like ready to
go back.
I'm like,
Jesus man.
Yeah.
And uh,
and then this morning I talked to him,
he's like,
um,
I'm going to run 10 miles today.
Oh right,
right.
Why?
And he goes,
just to lose weight.
I was like,
no.
It was like,
okay,
sounds good.
Sounds like the formula.
Most doctors and trainers recommend the hammer and they're like,
drink a lot but then run 10 miles.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But uh,
it got us to thinking about our own memorials.
Last night we came home,
I mean,
cause really Brody and they were showing clips of his stand up and it was so
fun.
Everybody was dying,
laughing,
cheering.
It was like Judd Apatow came and he even released the footage from funny people
used to always have this line when he was like,
I was in hangover,
hangover to due date.
I was cut out of funny people cut out of funny people always said that they,
they allowed him to whenever it showed the footage.
But um,
but I mean it got us to thinking about arts and my worst nightmare.
First of all,
if when I,
if not nine,
if when I die do not fucking play my early material,
my early stand up.
It's so embarrassing.
Like I'm in a fucking white dress.
Remember that old should I used to do just just to be,
I mean just let me preface it by saying that back in the day,
this is a decade ago,
there was no fucking me too movement and comedy is even way more sexist than it
is today.
And so this girl,
April Macy and I had to come up with a hook just to get fucking book cause I
would never touch a female comedian really unless you're super,
super famous.
So we came up with this thing naughty and sort of Nice and I was sorta Nice.
She's naughty and she's the devil and I'm the,
it was like the stupidest thing ever and I were wondering if we had to take,
just to get into these d clubs to work my way up the circuit.
But man,
do not play fucking any clips from my early stand up.
I will die of embarrassment and the,
I can just see it too.
They're like,
Christina was a great a comedian.
She did a lot of work on the Fart Mike and then like cut to me farting show.
Yeah.
Like what?
What's my contribution?
Like not,
not as much as Brodie,
you know,
doing,
you'd be as beloved as him.
No,
no.
I think like maybe these guys that we employ,
like blue band,
Josh,
she's like,
well I'm on the payroll.
I guess I have to,
cause Tom's still alive.
Tom's got to pay us.
She's just so,
they're like,
no,
we want to be here.
And they're like,
how fucking long is this thing?
I don't know.
I,
I think I'd be,
I don't know.
What do you want?
What's your worst nightmare is of a memorial memorial?
I don't know about my worst nightmare.
I can't imagine that many people going,
I just don't want my standup shower.
Like that would be the worst.
I'd want all my specials played.
You know,
everyone has to watch them all.
You have to lie.
You have to lock every sin,
every joke,
every,
it's all,
come on.
No,
I definitely wouldn't want that.
I don't know.
I can't imagine that many people would go,
well,
like last night when I saw all that love for him,
I was like,
there's no way this would have happened.
So when people love to,
yeah,
no,
I think people would be like,
Christina never came on my podcast.
I had asked her a lot of times.
She's like,
nope,
too busy.
Tom Doesn't text me back.
Never.
Uh,
I used to text
him and never texted me back.
Well,
you,
especially because you're,
you're way more antisocial.
I'm Elise nice to people.
I think people will be like,
did he have a family?
Like they wouldn't even be like a homeless guy on the street.
Yeah,
no,
I don't think it would go that well.
I don't think so either.
For me it was amazing.
Like his was amazing.
It was really like,
uh,
I dunno,
a comforting experience,
uh,
surrounding something that's obviously terrible,
but um,
it was like,
to see so many people remember someone like that was really a wonderful,
beautiful,
you think about what a piece of shit you are.
Just me.
Like,
I'm so selfish.
I don't,
I don't like make an effort to hang out with people other than my family ever.
Yeah.
I don't make an effort and you know,
I don't make an effort either.
I even make an effort with,
yeah,
like don't even feel like a,
I mean we have,
we have a seven month old and a three year old and then this and then Stan,
I'm like,
I don't,
I don't have the effort come out in the house.
They were like,
you know,
he just always talking about offstage,
just wanted to make you laugh,
make you laugh.
It's such a Dick.
I know.
I don't care.
I don't care either.
Did you go fucking giggle on your own?
I know and they were like,
he just wanted to spread joy and make the world and was like,
that's definitely not my goal.
No,
I'm just like I get in,
I get out,
just want to go home and sleep.
One of his friends was like,
and then like Brody got a show and comedy central and he flew down his friend
that he made a promise to like 20 years when we both started bawling.
I noticed both of you are like,
that's a real gentleman.
Like the men in the audience.
You guys really respected that I can tell you of course,
cause it's how a high character move so that the things she's talking about,
they said that like one of his buddies that he started out with,
they were like,
if we ever have one of us ever makes it.
They used to do all these kite cable access shows together.
One was ever makes it in Hollywood.
We'll bring the other one along and like 20 years went by and then he got a
comedy central show and on his own dime he flew that dude down from Seattle and
was like,
help me make this show.
Yeah,
of course.
You know,
it'd be really neat when we die.
Is that the,
uh,
the mommies that your mom's house fans will bring different shit related items?
It'll be like fake turds,
toilet paper,
and then there'll be like an altar that would really not like fake duties or
really wouldn't like that.
No,
I know it'd be terrible.
Yeah,
because we already have all of it that we already have this.
But guys,
thanks.
Thank you.
Please don't bring me here though.
Thank you though.
Very thoughtful.
Yeah.
I won't be remembered that kindly.
You don't think so?
Not by strain.
Not by like that many people.
Yeah.
Like are,
you know,
my family,
my children.
Hopefully you,
yeah.
Hopefully.
What,
but how long before I'm dead before you get married again?
I don't know.
It could be a great week.
Could be.
Yeah,
could be a long time.
It'd be a whole month.
Okay.
I could really parlay your death and this sweet person moving right along.
Are you down with this?
I mean,
I'm just saying like if I'm like,
Ooh,
I miss her and then you know,
some chicks like to listen to you,
the cackling.
It's true.
She could be like,
oh my God,
are you so alone?
Like I am alone.
I just want to feel the touch of another person.
You're saying that Patton Oswald played it wrong.
Jesus Christ.
Why didn't you take it there?
Well,
that's what that was what happened to him.
His wife died.
And you're saying he should have played the field more,
but no,
I didn't say that.
Picking,
I didn't find that at all.
Oh,
but well you're,
you're,
you're jumping it.
Oh,
okay.
I just thought it was a good parallel.
No,
it's a terrible parallel.
But you're saying you play the field more,
you'd use sympathy to get laid.
I'm saying Jesus,
when you saying,
I'm saying you're are worded number one.
Okay.
And I'm saying that I would get a lot of pussy.
Oh my God.
Anyways,
yesterday I was at the mall.
I wonder where the best place would be to get it for you.
Yeah,
probably the comedy club.
You think so?
Yeah.
That's where it slots Rpa at the comedy club.
We don't go out.
You don't do anything else social?
Where are you going to go?
Yeah,
that's a good point.
Grocery store.
Oh,
you don't even go there.
He's our mom.
That's true.
It's the Korean.
I shift for gears.
Okay.
Anyways,
um,
I was at the Mall,
Aka our country club yesterday,
and I fucking saw,
this is crazy dude.
I saw a security guard with no legs.
Yeah.
Like a security or with a badge.
And then he was in a wheelchair,
no legs.
And I'm like,
Hey man,
I'm all about equal opportunity and you know,
and the employment.
But just from a practical perspective,
it's ridiculous.
Like how are you going to fucking chase ridiculous a thief?
Or how are you going to stop some shit in your chair and your fucking wheelchair
rolls.
Symbolic job.
Right.
That's totally ridiculous.
I like it.
And it just gets my,
gets me fired up because everybody,
you know,
we're all about fat models and everybody's equal.
And everybody,
it's like,
no,
you're not bro.
Like there,
there are certain things,
we're not all equal.
It's,
you can't do everything.
Yeah.
I can't,
I shouldn't be a body guard.
Right.
Do you know what I mean?
My build my strength level.
Like what?
Yeah,
yeah.
I know.
It's ridiculous.
I mean,
a guy with no legs should be able to get a job.
Right.
But like that guy,
you know,
of all the jobs that could give them at the mall,
security guard would probably be dead last,
last,
last on the line and make them,
I don't know,
administrative or something.
Right.
Like even work at the Orange Julius
making juices.
Yeah.
For sure.
Yogurt land or the information desk wears Orange Julius and get the jobs right
there.
That's a great job.
Yeah.
Uh,
but yeah,
that's no good.
And I'm,
Josh Potter said that he saw a little person security guard.
It's also,
or blue band.
No,
that's Eurydice an LP security guard.
You know,
it's also ridiculous is that I saw a guy who was also missing some,
my God,
this dude,
and I'm not kidding,
you don't see this often,
but he had a no hit.
I walked behind him.
I hate this so much for I hate you.
I fucking hate that you post this.
Cause then I thought about it all day.
He has no head bay.
He has no head.
And I walked behind him.
I took photos,
I took videos,
I posted it.
And people were like,
you're an asshole.
I was like,
why?
And they were like,
well this guy is disabled.
Like no,
it just doesn't have a head.
Just walks around with no head.
I mean,
look,
you can play this video.
Oh my God.
In the lobby there.
Cool.
So terrifying.
Let's see.
Hair from behind.
That is terrible.
It's a,
I looked it up.
His dropped head syndrome.
Fucking crime.
The weakened muscles in his neck because he's looking down at his iPhone for too
many.
Probably.
Yeah.
I think maybe with him at something else.
But yeah,
that is the most depressing thing I've ever seen.
Yeah.
But he never misses a quarter and never,
never stumbles.
Never trips over a crack in the sidewalk.
Nope.
Would you say,
Ooh,
God's going to punish you?
Yeah,
he made fun of it too far.
You're going straight to hell.
I uh,
I sent the picture to my dad.
We're going to play this and your memorial by the land
rest and help.
My Dad just wrote no head.
Just a question mark.
Like,
like it was a legit question.
I was like,
yeah.
And he was like,
oh,
like that guy has no head.
Can I tell you of all the,
I mean,
look man,
aging is whore.
Stop
what?
You're going to hell bro.
You're fucking straight there.
Oh.
Oh God.
You got to straighten my back right now and get that started soothing.
So straight out of that shit.
I did.
I was,
I was even looking at my phone after this and I was like,
right,
fine.
That's RAF Apple Saba.
I mean,
look,
aging is fucking brutal as it is.
But then when you got something like this going on,
oh my life,
or you see old people with mechanical lunch in their bank that still fuck,
look at that.
Life is not fair.
Life is brutal.
Hey,
this guy still has like,
you know the character and the desire to go out,
right?
Oh,
I would be a shut in his there.
Nothing you can do.
I would be a shut in.
I can't prop that up.
Yeah.
And then he's put a brace on at least.
What causes that?
Just years of poor posture.
You're the worst person in the whole world.
Why Bay?
What?
This is bad.
Oh it's so,
it's so horrible.
Horrible.
Now
how unfair is life now?
I know it's terrible.
I seriously though,
if this happened to me,
I would just be a shut in.
Like I would,
I would just lock myself in a room and cry all day long.
Why?
I'm so shallow and weak inside.
Like I don't have this spirit to live.
Try it for a second.
Nope.
I don't want to curse it.
Just looked at,
oh wow.
Just look down how you get head scratch all day.
I know I have a cavity and I start crying.
It's great to get scratch my own head easily.
Just do this.
Other people would just think you want her because she would just walk up and
they would see the top of your head and they'd be like,
hey,
how you doing?
He'd be like,
good for the,
both of them are corrupt.
When does it affect my speech?
When am I talking about your sisters?
Oh my God.
How does he drink and eat?
Because you have to tilt your,
oh,
he's fine.
It's just a gag.
He was just doing this for awhile.
He saw that there were kids around and he's like,
you want to see his kids freak out and then this should be the poster for,
don't spend so much time on your phone.
It really should.
We should show this to my children immediately.
You're cruel.
Can we take this down?
I don't want to make fun of
your,
the cruelty champion,
not me.
You're the one making fun of his posture.
You post this show on Instagram.
I did it to make a point to look up and sit straight.
Alright.
Posture is important everywhere right
now it's gone.
Anyways,
bigger talking points.
We started a house of farts we caught up on.
I gotta tell you we were the biggest
house of cards fans,
uh,
for those of you,
um,
that had been listening to the show for a few years.
So they,
you know,
there was the big scandal,
Kevin Spacey.
What did he end up doing?
Did we find out?
For sure.
I put on deodorant today.
Uh,
you asked me as we left the house,
Babe.
Fuck God.
God.
Jesus.
It was,
I have to have Allie get me some deodorant.
I can't do this all day.
Sweating.
I mean the whole,
just the image.
What is this song?
It doesn't smell,
but it doesn't smell like I just turned and I just see,
yeah,
I need to put something there.
Oh,
I'll stop it.
My whole life is watching you smell your fingers.
I feel like small day.
I want you to either twist or nuts or smell your fingertips.
I do at one time in 15 years.
I all my fingers,
I need deodorant.
I'm going to text alley.
Right.
Oh my God,
I can't,
I can't go without deodorant.
Anyway,
Kevin Spacey was accused of harassing men on set and then he was accused of
sexually assaulting men,
young men both many years ago.
And then,
yeah,
minors and one kid at a party and another kid at a restaurant.
And I know it's,
it's a lot of allegedly sexual misconduct.
Okay.
And then he was fired from house of cards and they still made the final season
without them and I got to tell you
they should bring him back.
Nope.
They're like,
I don't care who he touched.
He's so good talent.
That show fucking sucks without them.
No,
I disagree.
I,
I'm enjoying it.
I'm into it.
It took me a minute to get used to it without him.
He's,
I'm enjoying a good guy.
He's an amazing character guy.
Our actor.
I would,
I like Claire.
I like seeing her world,
mourn her,
figuring out the world.
Without it.
I would allow him,
me too,
to bring this show to do a scene with him.
Like if they were like,
you can do a scene with Kevin Spacey but he's going to fondle you,
I'd be like,
all right.
Would you let him?
What would you let him do?
What did,
what are the options?
I mean,
would you let him put his mouth on you on your pener?
Sure.
Seriously.
I told you anybody could do that.
I don't care anybody,
anybody,
anybody final your beans.
Sure.
Poker behold,
behold any behold the holds kind of.
Here's the thing about the B hole is like,
I just keep thinking about that physical I got and uh,
it is fucking rough.
Yeah,
but the doctors more vigorous with you.
There was a lot of chocolate in there.
He had to get,
no,
he didn't was all hard.
He didn't,
he didn't know it was mushy.
I remember he was like,
you need to wipe up
gross anyway,
but I'll tell you something.
I like it.
A spacey,
it,
he really does.
Or a great actor just elevates something so much that it stood out.
I was so excited to finally,
cause we have,
I don't know,
we got distracted.
We didn't watch,
I started watching episode of the final season
and I realized like 20,
30 minutes in,
I was zoning out.
I wasn't even paying attention.
You're also not bright.
No,
no,
I understand.
It's different.
I like it though.
I do like it.
Yeah.
I'm sticking with it.
I mean,
I like to see how she navigates the world without him.
And maybe I'll give it another shot.
But I will say that everything,
cause there's a lot of preposterous,
ridiculous shit in that show.
And when you have an unbelievable act or it actually grounds it,
cause this is a silliness.
He's just mean.
I fucking,
I don't know.
Silly.
He's a,
he should have done what he allegedly did,
allegedly.
Allegedly.
Of course you have to say allegedly.
Yeah.
Wow.
You remember,
uh,
yesterday on the way to the memorial.
What?
I farted in the car.
Fucking remember it.
That was terrible.
Your fart.
Can I tell you what was really bad about it?
Is that,
I don't know how you managed to do it,
but your farts smelled like the bathroom and lax,
you know when you go and everyone's taking their shifts and then the smell of
like 10 stranger international dumps makes one horrendous smell.
Statute.
What?
It smelled blinded from De Moines.
Other guys from New Delhi and Hong Kong Shit together.
Yes.
And then it smells like one horrendous smell.
Good.
It did.
It's all like a public restroom.
It was so the airport really rare and really special as it.
Cool.
What,
walk me through what you ate to get that.
Yesterday was a good day.
Um,
I made fitness.
I had eggs in the morning.
Um,
he's a bacon.
Okay.
You're not being,
I'm being honest coming.
You're not.
I am.
Oh.
And then I had that seafood.
That's what it is.
What it was.
It was a mix.
Seafood dish for lunch that had like a little piece of Salmon,
shrimp,
uh,
Calamari,
all grilled and um,
yeah.
Far did it smell like people who were in my asshole dying.
Okay.
Um,
let's,
uh,
let's explore the new member.
They guitars,
everything.
There's a guy who's actually part of the rich guy.
Club eyes are sweating my bad.
I didn't realize how rich he was.
Um,
this guy is so bad ass boy.
You haven't seen this dude yet,
right?
No.
I don't know who the,
I don't know who this is.
His name is Michael.
Is that right?
Right,
isn't it Michael?
Yeah.
And this dude is,
he's got to be,
I would say in his fifties,
and he's just posting pics of himself with money,
with girls Gig.
I'm getting my Dick Suck.
Um,
oh,
here's the amount of sympathy
I have for you.
Broke bitches money made Michael.
He,
he died his beard in that picture.
Yeah,
it looks awesome.
Here's a picture of where he says it's a new night,
which means a new pussy to be bought.
So he's got the ball.
I got new shoes.
He's rocking Jordans.
This dude is 50.
He probably weighs about two 90 to three 15.
Oh,
that's flattering help.
I'm at a girl's house and her boyfriend just came home.
He's always out there doing scandalous shit,
but he's,
uh,
he's always pretty happy,
you know.
Um,
he gets,
I don't know.
Do you have any of the other,
uh,
Fiddes or,
or photos
go to his,
uh,
oh,
do you want to read some of these?
What he's saying to other people?
Right.
So he's like International Women's Day and tribute of this day.
I will go and support female sex workers near me.
That's pretty cool.
Black and Latina ladies do it best.
Kay.
So you're ugly and broke.
Tough life praying for you versions before I go to sleep.
It's always the people with no money talking shit about me.
Some of his tweets.
Yeah.
How'd you tell us how you found this guy?
Why pull up his Twitter?
How I found them?
Yeah.
Uh,
I just,
I happen a lot of his tweets,
you know,
for not having like a huge social media presence.
A lot of his tweets get like a lot of retweets and likes,
you know,
like pretty substantial.
Um,
he just died.
That beer belly looks really good.
Um,
he's got a stack of cash next to his head on his Twitter banner.
Yeah.
Which is Kinda neat.
Big Why and crack reaction.
I wonder what kind of office he works at cause he's always posting from the
office.
Yeah.
I've been scoring so much to the ladies.
I might say fuck it and play for both teams.
Talking about second,
some dicks there.
Um,
what's this here?
What do we see in here?
This is,
what does it say in the caption though?
Can you read it?
I got the cheese.
I got the Cheddar.
You little broke boys could never boss up.
Um,
can you make that picture bigger by any chance?
This guy is a baller.
I mean,
is that cash though?
I don't know.
No,
no.
It's a cheeseburger cheese.
It's a,
I can't see,
I can't see it.
She's like American.
I got you a single.
So He's,
he's making his Cheddar joke.
That's what's up,
dude.
Yeah.
He's cool as shit.
I mean,
he's,
his clothes fit real nice.
I like his facial hair smiling at my haters.
That's a good attitude to have though.
And I'm not hating for the record.
I know Haiti.
I feel like this dude is,
but see what I'm saying?
It's ridiculous.
He know he got his watches is that swag attracts the ladies.
That's right.
You know you to put it out there like,
Hey,
I'm a fucking baller.
I have an expensive things till you get it.
That's right.
I'm not saying that's going to attract wife material,
but it's going to attract lady Oh oh shit.
Picture of him in a karate outfit is Yung Mi training to beat the pussy up.
Beat the pussy up.
I mean,
he definitely has a good sense of humor.
I'll give him that.
Oh.
Stacks stacks.
Roush got a grill.
He's holding.
Money's put money in a seatbelt in the car.
Yeah.
Shit.
But there's more,
there's more.
It gets better.
Um,
can it up?
He's got an eye patch here.
What happened was,
because my eye's messed up,
does it mean my penises Hashtag love my wife?
I don't know.
I don't understand what's happening there.
How about this one?
This is him wearing an eyepatch stupid bitch from last night.
Sat on my face and didn't even wash herself.
This is the second time this has happened.
Hmm.
He's in the hospital there.
I see that.
I think he's saying that someone's vagina gave his iron infection.
Is that what I'm supposed to
yeah,
sure.
Short left this.
Yeah,
it's a bitch button.
It's amazing.
Amazing.
How about this one?
No thanks.
You can read that.
You can't tell what my penis is getting sucked on right now and it's just a
photo of him sitting on the edge of the bed dressed up.
It's pretty cool.
That's him showing that ridiculous Kiosk Watch.
Um,
stop questioning my wealth.
His old school that is not
getting a phone call from my bitch.
Condos are those,
is that real money Tom?
Yeah,
I think that's money.
Yeah.
Although if it's the amount that he says it is,
those bands,
those bands would be a little more full.
But whatever.
Yeah,
he's having fun.
He's rich.
It was ridiculous.
Kinda going to go buy a sandwich and he's got a black visa card and he's just
showing you that debit.
It's a debit card.
Is that something like,
Oh shit.
Now.
We went from cool guys to rich guys,
Guy Club,
and he's super okay.
Nothing like that.
Early morning sex and he's kind of arrangement with his wife cause that was
like,
I don't know,
a lady at the sink who was not this lady.
I don't know what that was,
bro.
And he's just like,
oh,
I just fucked this chick.
I don't know what that's about.
Check this out.
He looks good.
They're going to go buy some pussy.
It's so,
it's so weird.
It's like the captions all wrong.
You know what I'm saying?
Like the caption on that picture should be like going to mow the lawn areas.
Going back to this,
the shack like it should not say that,
right?
Yeah.
I'm eating more than I should today.
Cheeseburgers all day.
This is you.
Poor people can't do stuff like me and he's always burning money,
burning a hundred dollar bill.
I don't know why people do that and know silliness.
That's just this reject.
Yeah.
Why would you do that?
Wow.
Because he has all that money,
Tom.
I know,
but it's just so fucking upsetting.
And now instead of a hundred dollar bill on fire,
the fuck man.
Oh,
okay.
This is a girl's girl.
But that music is probably gonna play on this,
so don't play that.
But yeah,
he's in the car.
Uh,
he spent my day with her.
I don't know the guy in the back,
she says it's a friend.
That's hilarious.
And there's a kid in the back,
he's just driving a chick who's like having fun dancing video.
She's gotta be 30 years younger than him.
Always cold on.
Involve children in your nonsense.
So what does his handle,
by the way,
the president of the Rich Guy Club?
It is Michael Daddy 51.
So He's into that sugar daddy life though.
This could be your future and time if I,
if you know,
if I'm gone or something.
This guy,
what I'm saying,
this is the don't test me.
Yeah,
but I'm saying this could be like end up the kind of thing you're doing is like
going out with a sugar daddy.
Really good.
I like where you're going with and what do you think?
But here's the thing,
I'm not sure I'm his type.
Well,
maybe you're not his type.
I used to be so skinny.
He posted.
Well,
he was rocking the same style though.
That's like 10 years ago.
I know,
but it's like the same style.
I mean,
that's,
it's not like a new thing that he's embraced.
The facial hair is exactly the same.
It's got the gold chain on.
Looks good.
It was a good luck then.
It's a great look now.
That's true.
That is true.
So you're saying that I should go for the sugar daddy route in case you Rowley.
I'm a wrist Jordan's on my feet.
Boy.
This dude is insane.
I love it.
I don't think I'd make a good sugar baby.
Tom,
check it out.
I can't handle this shit.
Your girl's house,
she says hi.
All right,
so he's got the grill and let's see.
Let's do the,
uh,
this right here.
No,
that's a nice grill.
I mean,
think maybe a dermatologist.
Me,
I'm blotching.
He needs to get a skin.
I could just be alcoholism
maybe.
But look,
dude,
you're definitely killing the game.
I mean,
he's got hose.
He's got money.
He's got Jordan's,
he's got diamonds in his mouth.
He's killing it for sure.
When I'm in love,
I can't think straight.
Oh No,
he's in love shit now.
Damn.
I didn't realize that.
God Damn.
Do you think you could love him for money?
Catch you allowed to get some head.
Wow.
You're lucky.
It's worth checking out.
If you're listening to the show,
give us the handle again.
Yup.
It's a,
it's Michael Daddy 51 it's worth a follow.
It is worth a comment.
He is really enjoying life.
I think he likes it.
No,
you're not.
You're not.
I know I'm saying,
but that type of,
I wish I were his type.
He seems like he's a really cool guy and he's a cool guy,
but I'm saying you,
I'm saying you might need a sugar daddy at some point.
Would you be open to that arrangement if it's the right guy
just takes you shopping and care about,
that's the thing.
I lean on me and my handbag problem and my,
I love expensive stuff.
Yeah.
I love that.
Can I say that?
It's such a crazy thing that people that they do that it was pretty crazy with
too short here.
I was still blown away that hookers don't get paid cash.
They just get paid and stuff.
Yeah.
I don't want to fucking handbag.
I want health insurance,
Bro.
I want a house.
Well,
I don't give,
give me fucking stuff.
You don't want stuff at all.
I don't want stuff bro.
Gimme like security.
Real,
real.
Yeah.
Maybe I could find a sugar daddy that would do that.
Would you be a sugar baby?
Would I be rich lady?
An older,
unattractive rich lady.
I kinda liked the idea.
Really.
You would do it.
You've got to stay super fit the job.
Here's the problem with being a sugar baby.
Your whole life revolves around pleasing your sugar daddy.
So your days are spent working out,
keeping yourself looking nice,
catering to hit his or her needs.
You have to think about them constantly.
That's true.
Well that's your job,
but that's your full time Gig.
Is that person?
I'm really not.
Nah,
you can't.
I can't do it.
I'd rather live in the gutter to,
I don't know.
It'd be,
yeah.
First of all,
if she's like,
Hey,
what's up with that gut and be like,
I mean,
I fucking worked out today.
And she was like,
well maybe do it again.
And I'll be like,
no,
no.
I'm not doing that shit.
Be so abusive.
Well,
me too.
What's up with those hanging tits?
I'm like,
I have two kids.
Well,
they would pull your tits up for you.
I don't want to do it though.
I kind of don't want to have surgery for that.
It seems crazy,
doesn't it?
I mean it's a put like blood sugar.
Daddy wants a bags of saline to show.
It's pretty like crazy.
That's what he liked.
I know that I have to do it.
So one thing that we can
talk about here,
you remember how you were licking your lips to the Laker game?
So they're not going to be in the post season.
They're like,
oh yeah,
what are you talking?
You're not good enough.
So,
but this off season.
Yeah,
they're doing some stuff to kind of keep the fans interested.
Fans like yourself.
So they,
they put out this video,
um,
and you can see whether you want to go to some of their off season at charities.
I'm talking about,
look at where is this.
Let's go look at that sweat.
I love it.
Is this Jamaica,
are you seeing,
I'm seeing,
I love it.
This is what I'm talking about.
This is why I love Laker Games.
It is a Dick Dance.
I love it.
I'm on board.
Let's go.
Yeah.
How much is airfare?
Where is it?
These guys [inaudible] you guys listening?
They're wearing loose fitting sweat shorts and the whole thing is they just
dance and their dick just swings around of it and you can see how enormous
they're dicks are and they all have,
is this going to get flagged for the song?
No,
no,
no.
We'll be all right.
Okay.
Um,
I'm out of mind.
The Dick's.
I just want the song get in the way,
Tom.
Yeah.
Where is the Dick swinging competition?
This is a,
at the Lakers facilities.
At the staples center.
Yeah.
This is,
no,
this is an Elsa Gundo.
I love this.
We're going immediately see,
this is why I want those floor seats at the Laker Games.
This is all we do is what happened.
You face labs is they walked by,
they run by,
but the Lakers need to start wearing looser fitting shorts and then I'm at every
game.
They know that too.
They know that.
Of course,
they know that.
Glad.
Do you mind if I ask you a funny question?
I have a funny question to ask you guys.
I'm not sure that's the right word.
Yeah.
Um,
it's pretty cool though.
The really good a question I ask.
Baba gloss of the house.
Your House.
Oh right.
Oh,
mom's house.
We'll be right back.
And we're back with a very highly anticipated guests that we super excited
about.
We were teasing this earlier.
Um,
the roast master General Jeff Ross.
Thank you so much for the bad.
You were talking earlier about last night and a what a beautiful night it was.
And I didn't want to spoil it because it was so amazing that,
you know,
people would get up there and they would tell stories about Brody and it was
childhood friends,
childhood baseball coach,
roommate from college.
Right.
And these guys are saying,
you know,
nice things and telling you some kind of funny,
the anecdotal side stuff.
But then it was beautiful.
I cried,
I cried during Zach.
He opened the whole thing up.
Right.
But what I'm saying is that like,
you know,
storywise they're like,
uh,
Brody used to come over and he would have dinner with us sometimes,
you know,
and,
and then you got up there and you opened the memorial year,
memorial time with,
what did you say?
Said,
um,
after hearing all these
childhood friends speak today,
I was starting to understand why Brody
killed him.
I was fucking fell down.
We were all sitting in a row together.
Bert Kreischer,
Tom Ryan,
sickler,
Brian,
where everybody just goes in a rupture than Manny.
Everybody died.
I was in the back
waiting and waiting and waiting and waiting and waiting for his college.
Literally this guy did half an hour.
Yeah,
he was.
He went along and you know,
I mean I noticed that the main room at the comedy store,
they only turn the lights on for the comics.
I noticed that all the civilians there,
they didn't put a light on comics had lights on.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean it was looking right up at it and they didn't turn it on for any
civilians.
There is a Fart Fart,
fart money.
Cause that's good to know.
Especially at drinking all this coffee.
Let your new coffee machine that he's a man.
You going to Fart.
I Dunno.
Brody would've would've really liked that.
Now hold on.
False alarm.
Oh my God.
I'm sorry.
Back to what we were saying.
Um,
anyways,
and then right after you said that they played the sound drop,
um,
of Brody's saying,
what is it like you get it or he gets [inaudible] the place.
Yeah.
It doubled the laugh.
You gave this fun.
You gave a great speech,
man.
Thanks a lot.
Thank you.
You're made for that you should do more eulogies and stuff.
I really do kill it.
Funerals
and I don't know why.
I remember going as a young comic to see,
I was so honored and I got invited to any young man's funeral and then later
Milton Berle's funeral and I went up speaking it.
Yeah,
Buddy Hackett's funeral.
I realized that those,
those moments is when you can really cut through people's agony.
Yeah,
and you got to do it.
We have almost have a responsibility when they ask you as a comedian,
even if it's a tough one.
I've spoken to,
some are tougher than others obviously.
If you're really close to the person for sure,
but yeah,
man,
you were really close with Hackett,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We were like,
we were like real good pals.
Did Not know this.
How did that come about,
Buddy Hackett,
if you don't know him?
He was a Catskills in New York comedian,
a talk down of the side of his mouth and I met him.
He was an Herbie the love bug movie in the 50s he was in a mad,
mad,
mad world and he had sitcoms,
but he was a huge nightclub comic and Vegas and Atlantic City Act,
you know,
making a couple hundred thousand a week in the 80s you know,
fuck right.
And he would come to the Friar's Club in New York to the,
and he befriended me after a roast.
Just thought it was funny and invited me out.
Well,
the first time I actually met him was it in an elevator at the friars club.
I got in the elevator and I was going to play poker with Greg Fitzsimmons and
Ilan gold and I wasn't even a member of this friar's club yet.
It's like a show Biz Club in New York.
And he tagged,
he tagged you up right away,
didn't he?
He must have seen you and said something.
No,
he,
he got in the elevator and I was just wearing my one good blazer.
Here we go.
Silent.
It's quiet.
The timing of a suicide bomber
talking about my dead friend
guys,
I can't control the biology.
All right,
sorry.
Go ahead as full time when you're dead friend.
It's funny that you farted because he got on the elevator buddy and he looked at
it and I said,
Mr Hackett,
I'm such a huge fan.
My parents who were their favorite comedian,
and I'm a comedian and it's such an honor to meet you.
And I shook his hand and he shook my hand.
He looked me in the eyes and said,
you know who hates far?
It's the most midgets.
They live at ASCE height.
And the elevator door opened.
I didn't see him again for a year.
And then he befriended me at the Steven Seagal roast.
I really killed.
And uh,
it was my first roast.
My opening joke there was pretty good too.
What was it?
I realized a lot of you don't know me,
but I feel uniquely qualified to be here today because I'm also a shitty actor.
Was this a golf game?
Was He,
uh,
no,
not really.
It doesn't seem like he would,
he was reasonably game,
but I don't think he got it all.
And Yeah.
You know,
there's a lot of stories about him not being cool.
Yeah.
A lot
and,
and it was a wonderful night where Milton burrow and Buddy Hackett sort of
adopted me and I improvised with them.
And uh,
during the roast,
that was my first rows back when they really couldn't get people and,
and then buddy said,
gave me his phone number,
what it down and said,
next time you're in Los Angeles,
com look me up.
And I took,
it took me a year to call him and I finally called him and I went over for
Brunch,
sat in his backyard and he was like a mentor but in a weird way he was like a
big kid too.
And I was like an old man even when I was like 30.
Yeah.
This was a long time ago and we were like brothers sort of met in the middle
somewhere.
It was fun.
I try out all my jokes on him and he was a great sounding board and comedy was
like number five on the list of stuff he was an expert on.
He knew everything about relationships and politics and religion and he
collected guns and he,
he's just an interesting dude.
I like old guys too.
Yeah.
I can hang out with old people.
Yeah,
I love it.
Yeah.
It's more fun.
Like we were just talking about this like really old sexist guys.
Like old white guys were saying you were hanging out with a friend of ours.
Yeah,
the dad and he was like,
what's that thing in a skirt abroad?
Like that gun.
Is that,
yeah,
it's just like,
it feels like you're stepping into a time machine,
but it makes me laugh.
I
don't know.
They also like,
I mean they want you,
those guys always want you to joke.
Yeah,
sit down for a good term.
They're fun,
which is fun.
And they live like it's her last planner or they'll fuck around with the
waitress.
Don't go with a guy and track grandfather used to,
he used to,
my grandfather was so crazy.
I used to live with my grandfather after college and he was a retired
construction worker.
I'm wearing his ring,
so I think about him all the time.
I tap it on metal.
There's a bolt from a Nazi submarine that he took off in World War II when he
was in the U s coast guard.
He made a ring out of it anyway,
he used to,
he just,
he was so fearless.
When he got to be about in his late seventies there was this route 22 it through
Union New Jersey near where we live this highway and you know,
all the shops were like in the middle lane,
so he'd have to do,
you turns to get to the other place.
He's real and this is a highway.
He would,
he would,
he,
if somebody was annoying in front of them or wouldn't go,
he would bump them.
Oh my God.
He just didn't care.
He had,
they just didn't carry,
it wasn't going to hurt anybody,
but he just,
he would pump people with his fender,
just bumping into their car in front of them just to fuck with pets.
Other level.
Yeah,
he was the best.
Yeah.
It was so funny.
He used to stare at what does a diner diner on route 22 I think it was called,
the lead out.
I forgot.
And,
um,
we'd sit in a diner eating our breakfast and he looked out the window and his
bank across the highway,
across the three lane highway and he on the Sunday he left,
he,
he'd be like,
does this door look unlocked?
I was like,
I got over $300 in areas.
Like it's just funny guy.
They left the door,
the Baco,
but he's worried about his 300.
So funny.
Yeah.
I can hang out.
Like hanging out with my friend's dad who's in his seventies was like,
it was a,
it was a thrill.
Like every,
every other line was a fucking,
you know,
inappropriate thing to say that nobody says it anymore.
It's inappropriate.
And it's also the source of saying that,
you know,
it's an old guy.
He's not saying it really to be malicious.
[inaudible] himself.
I wonder if I'll still be funny when we're old.
Think about it.
Don't you think about it?
I mean,
there,
there must be some secret to staying relevant or at least staying funny.
Yeah.
Because you see a lot of old people,
they,
their drugs become corny or uh,
they're so rich or six are lazy.
They don't,
they're gonna lose their edge.
You'd have insight into this.
What's the secret?
I think I think either have it or you don't kind of a thing.
I feel like if you don't lose the internal struggle,
you stay funny.
Yeah.
You get too comfortable.
You get boring at the very least.
Or You just become,
I don't know.
Why are,
why are police records better than stings?
Records?
What happens when you get successful?
How do you keep it going?
Why was Joan Rivers hilarious
at 18 when maybe other people make it to 80 and their drugs are like,
Huh,
yeah,
she's wild shit.
And I got to see her like a couple years before she passed and man,
she was saying shit that nobody was saying like she was brave and you're like,
that's what it is.
That's where it should be.
You just say wild shit.
And I think there's such a license to ill.
The older you get,
like,
don't you feel like you give a fuck far less.
The older I'm like,
I don't give a fuck.
I'm gonna die soon.
Like I feel like I'm 42 now and I'm like,
I don't have that much time left.
Really.
Maybe 30 good years maybe.
Fuck all y'all.
I don't give a fuck.
Who's going to remember this shit?
Who's going to care?
Somebody will care.
Maybe
part of the reason you do the podcast,
you do the standup,
you do the special if you want to lead some sort of legacy.
No,
because I don't think people do remember like I feel like,
I mean how many people know who Buddy Hackett is and that guy was just here.
Millions.
He died.
Just three.
Yeah.
Carlin.
I mean people already are,
I feel like forgetting,
don't know.
I mean he still has definitely millions of fans.
Oh,
sure.
Best for sure.
Anyway,
I think you were,
I think we're both right in this case.
People forget quickly.
Yeah,
they do,
but theirs.
But the people that were affected by it.
Yeah.
Who you know,
dude,
it's like took in what you did for sure.
Very remember like it.
Yeah.
That's one day you'll have a podcast studio named after you or there'll be a
statute.
It'll be your head instead of that fucking dog right there.
But dude,
I was going to tell you this,
I,
because I've always been a big fan of yours.
I remember seeing you.
Thanks.
When I was starting out doing standup.
Yeah,
no,
I'm at a stoplight and a white port too far too for,
you're a fan.
One fired for not a fan.
Yeah,
I'm working on it.
White Porsche Boxster.
Was that a car or you're right.
Yeah.
See,
I remember seeing you.
Wow.
I'm a stop light at a stoplight.
Jeff Ross right there.
Wow.
That was pretty,
that was pretty early in standup and then,
and then you were very,
very nice.
I had a lot of anxiety on the first night of odd ball and I saw you in the
coffee shop and the at the hotel and you know,
I,
I kind of expressed it to you and then I didn't since I didn't know you really.
I was like,
well,
who knows if like how you're going to take it.
Like it could be like,
you know,
we'll stop being a bitch or something.
Right.
All right,
cool.
Thanks man.
But you were very nice about it and you actually really,
I was more anxious than I was letting on.
You really talked me down in the nicest way.
It was a big crowd and you had to follow a big act.
And I also had a bad experience at one of the empathy,
like bad meeting.
Like I just didn't enjoy it right now,
but that's nice.
That's,
yeah,
that's a,
that's an aside from the fact that like you're talking about like how do you
stay doing it?
Don't you feel like,
I always feel like you're the guy who's coming up with these most creative ways
to do,
like everyone does a special where it's like,
I come out and I just,
you know,
this is my act.
And you're like,
all right.
That's what a standup special is.
But you've taken like a spin on it and done.
You know,
you did one at the border wall,
you've turned him in jail.
You know,
you're always pushing it though.
You're always,
you know,
bumping Mike's is like all,
it's all different.
Yeah.
You know?
I don't know where he,
one day I should do a,
and I wanted to see how things work out,
but I mean,
what,
why,
why do you think I'll get a wife and a podcast?
Why do you think you do it that way?
I mean,
was that plan to like,
that's gotta be different?
It can't just be a special,
I think it wasn't a special as it was my act that was starting to evolve where
like I want her to keep roasting,
but I didn't want to be predictable and I didn't want to repeat myself and I
wanted roasting to become broader cause I,
I was,
I was loving it.
Yeah.
And
it became where I just didn't want to do regular standup anymore.
Audiences.
We're getting more and more rambunctious and the Internet and social media was
causing
me to be more interactive with my audience anyway.
And I feel like I started bringing people up on stage and speed roasting them.
And that's Kinda how it started.
And once it became about the audience for the second half of my show,
I was like,
Huh,
well who's the best person or roast?
How about like guys in orange jumpsuits?
That might be funny.
Yeah.
And then you go,
or how about women in orange jumpsuits and how about,
how about the next one?
I roast cops on the job or were these ever Tufts sells like when you would pitch
this very difficult,
really not just to comedy central,
uh,
but to,
you know,
my team obviously and,
and um,
and you know,
the jails themselves and the police precincts and the,
the border towns like wherever I go,
it's got,
it gets easier,
but the ideas get harder.
So it's a little bit of a catch 22 where you want to keep taking big swings,
but it doesn't get any easier.
Right.
You supposed to get easier.
I remember in the jail one,
uh,
something about in,
in that were you,
they told you they're like,
oh,
we told the guys like if they were to act up for like the last six months and
they couldn't come to the show.
Right.
And so then everyone was on good behavior.
So that helped.
And then we also told,
uh,
we also made all the murderers sit like up front.
Yeah.
Safety issue.
Uh,
the,
the jail administrator,
Wayne Dickey,
Brazos county jail in Texas said,
well,
we're ready for ya.
I said,
I'm ready to come.
Can I come soon?
And he goes,
well,
can we delay it a month?
Cause I want to use this to incentivize good behavior.
Oh,
that's cool.
That makes sense.
Yeah,
I guess so.
You get something out of it.
The jail gets up mad of it.
And uh,
and then when I got there,
we had a safety meeting.
I said,
isn't her army having a safety meeting?
He goes,
no,
there's not much for you to know.
We got it all here in our hands.
I go,
well there's where a guy with a gun behind,
no,
no guns in a jail.
Huh?
So how does this work?
And you know,
they didn't want to tell me too much cause I didn't want me to be nervous,
but I said,
well basically they let on that,
oh here's what happened.
And the first show I did two shows on the first show.
I said,
where am I murder is that kind of as a joke?
And three guys on the front row raised their hand and I took a step back,
like surprise.
And we had a,
you know,
that show went and I uh,
in between shows,
I said to the two,
Wayne,
I said,
why are the,
is up front?
He goes,
oh,
that's the safest place for them to be.
Ah.
I said,
why?
He goes,
well,
if anything happens,
they're the closest to the where we can get at them,
but they're also the closest to me.
And they go,
yes,
but we can get you out easier too.
If these are the guys that are most likely to fight,
they're the most likely to,
you know,
those are the ones we want in the front,
but yet in the balcony,
the farthest way in the corner or the guys with the swastikas on their stomachs
and chess,
Jesus' soul,
it was,
there was no real like easy breezy spot in that room.
Is there like a,
a kind of relief leaving though?
Even like you have fun doing the show or you're like kind of good to be out of
there when you wrap?
Yeah,
I mean I,
I definitely took a couple of big deep breath.
Yeah.
Walking in and walking out of that place.
Ballsy idea,
man.
Brave.
Were you ever afraid?
Always afraid this could go.
If I make a swastika joke about the guy in the back with a swastika,
I wasn't even sure.
And you don't want to humiliate anybody so they all have to be volunteers more
or less to come to the show.
Yeah.
And I did make a speech at the end saying everything I said is a joke.
And you know,
if I called some guy in nickname or a funny joke named that shouldn't stick,
you know,
like I didn't want somebody to be bullied raw in the wrong way that I was
roasting.
Cause roasting is,
is anti bullying.
You know,
that's how I started roasting lists when I was getting bullied as a kid.
I sort of making fun of the bully and then he left me alone.
Yeah.
And he was not verbal,
but he was like hitting me and pushing people around.
But yeah,
I felt real good leaving.
I mean I was there for a week and that particular instance,
um,
Eh,
you know,
but I also was like,
I felt really lucky the whole time that I did have it take it out of there
because you know,
he sold a few joints in high school.
I could have gotten busted.
I had the advantage of being white.
I had the advantage of being careful,
you know,
and not doing it for too long.
But we all do dumb shit when we're kids.
And not all of us,
but most of us.
Oh I did shoplifting and chorus,
breaking people's mailboxes and tagging things and,
but do you find that and then look,
cause I as a female comedian,
wow.
It looks like he's hearing this for the first day.
Smashing mailboxes.
Yeah.
It was kind of angry as a teenager.
Um,
I find is a,
is a,
is a lady,
I get away with a lot of shit on stage.
Yeah.
Nobody expects me to say anything or do anything.
So when I,
and I can fucking pick on people and it's what are they going to do?
Hit a woman.
But for you,
do you find that because you're a man,
do some guy could fucking come after you after a show and be like,
what's so funny guy?
I feel like that's always happened growing up in New Jersey,
like starting out comedy in New Jersey,
New York.
You didn't need to even be a Rosca.
Any comment?
Any,
I mean,
I saw a guy take a swing at John Stewart once very early in our careers and I
saw a guy came on stage once,
twice in my early career and just pulled the mic out of my hand.
You know,
really intimidating people.
Yeah.
I mean I had that roasting instinct,
but none of the skill to back it up and none of the reputation,
it was just,
I was just some fucking jerk.
Yeah.
You know,
I was missing a lot,
you know,
trying and,
and then you know,
even like at the jail for instance,
I wasn't even always worried about insulting someone in pissing them off because
that would be in front of everybody.
I was worried about the whole week I was there or when I brought people on stage
and get speed roasted.
Somebody who premeditated.
Just wanting to be a show off.
Yeah.
You're in there for life anyway.
How let's Shank this goofy guest.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'll be a legend around here.
Let me just put him in a headlock for five seconds.
Let me just punch him in the face and it'll be hilarious forever.
Like,
that's more what I'm worried about.
I was worried about have you got me worried about it right now?
But there's a,
there was a real trust factor between me,
myself,
the inmates and the,
and the jailers and it all worked out.
Okay.
What is your best,
cause I mean I was definitely not my lane,
but what is your best advice for people who are like,
oh,
how do I get good at roasting?
You know,
what do you tell people?
Well,
at the level I'm at,
I feel like listening is the part that I really have to concentrate on and,
and you can't take for granted,
you know,
what's,
what's coming at you and your reactions to that is really important.
Like,
I'll ask somebody,
uh,
you know,
I had,
I had a lady on stage this weekend,
um,
she hobbled up on stage to get speed roasted with her husband.
I think volunteers from the audience,
I don't pick them.
They pick,
they,
they volunteer and this lady hobbled up on stage with crutches and she had,
you know,
half a leg missing.
So to me it's not me starting off with a bunch of jokes.
It's about going like,
so this is your husband,
how long have you two been married?
You know,
and let her kind of get into it so that my reactions are roasty.
Right.
Not necessarily the first drug that usually backfires when you fire first.
That's interesting.
But I let her sort of pun walk into it a little bit.
Yeah.
And then once I got to know her and I saw her haircut and her outfit,
I was like,
you know,
losing your half of your leg is like number five on the shit that's fucked up
about it.
And by then you know,
she's even over,
her tits are bunching up and down.
She's convulsing with laughter and her husband is just falling on the floor
because that's awesome.
They don't,
you know,
disabled people sadly are never normalized there,
always treated so differently.
So I think she was looking for some,
some heat.
She wanted to laugh at her predicament and she had cancer.
And when I finally asked her what happened,
you know,
she was young enough to be like a veteran of the war,
but you don't see many female amputees.
So I said,
you know what,
you want to tell us what happened or something to that effect.
And she said she has cancer and,
and,
and the audience kind of,
you know,
felt for her.
And I hugged her and I asked her how she's feeling now.
She said she's feeling great.
And then this other,
this weird old lady standing along the line,
they get waiting to get speed roasted,
who had already made fun of for five minutes.
Just some Wacko lady.
Like who was just like trying to feel me up and smacking me and just,
just a nutjob from the audience.
Um,
we just ran down the stage and hugged her and I said,
all right,
well now you survive cancer,
now you have aids.
So you know,
just like letting the audience kind of come to you a little bit really helps
with the road.
So you use your reaction.
He really just got to hold your tongue.
You know,
you might have an idea,
but sometimes the audience will do the set up and you'd just have to do the
punchline.
Yeah,
that's good advice man.
He said,
man,
in the bumping mix she's wearing like a Hawaiian shirt.
Fuck.
Did he say to her,
you're like,
get back on the cruise or thank you for coming from the crews because they did.
They look like they just gotten out of like some fucking cruise ship.
And I think that's it.
I can't remember exactly.
I think I called you and astronauts wife.
Then Dave said that he had to drop her off at the,
uh,
at the carnival cruise ship or something.
You know,
like once I started they will knock it down or you know.
Oh
No.
Sound effects.
That's all real.
Does that register
and the Emmy for Best Fart?
One thing about,
first of all,
if you guys haven't seen bumping Mike's Jeff Ross and David's not pumping that
mic,
that one,
cause it smells real too.
But the uh,
the,
there's very,
it's very rare that you know,
as
a comics do you'd watch more than like how much like five minutes of specials.
I see how it all starts.
We ripped through all of that.
I texted you.
I was like,
man,
this is so fucking funny.
I love that.
We love you guys just like you're the,
you know,
our favorite comics and then I dunno,
watching the,
the camaraderie,
all that was great.
The one thing that I was like,
Holy Shit that I can't even wrap my head around is that you eat before shows.
Like this one thing I can't really,
because I get how funny he is a great comic,
but I'm sitting there like I can't believe how he's eating right now.
And he's like eating before shows,
eating on stage.
At one point I wondered Mozzarella sticks to the Dash.
Can you eat before right before a show and a half
I'll be hungry.
Feed a hearty meal.
I won't have like steak and potatoes.
I have to have a little something.
Oh,
that'd be a warmup for him.
Potatoes.
I like to,
if I'm doing two shows are a big long thing,
especially with the hotel where I kind of like run around and keep up with them.
I need my carbs.
Like food doesn't slow me down.
It fuels me.
Really.
Food and coffee.
I need carbs in coffee,
carbs and caffeine.
Oh,
I can't drink.
You can't drink?
No,
I can't drink before I go on an important show.
I did have a sip of Tequila before I went on last night at Brody's memorial.
But for the most part,
if it's a show where I'm,
I gotta be on my game and people are paying to see me,
it's all carbs and caffeine.
I'd rather be a little hungry than full at all.
And now I love a post show feast.
I love it.
But you know,
yeah,
I eat before and after.
Um,
I don't do really do drugs.
I'm not a big drinker.
I mean,
food is the thing.
No.
Yeah,
me too.
I just,
I mean,
I dunno.
I always feel like whenever,
every time I've eaten like anything of substance on stage,
I'm like,
fuck.
Like,
I want a burp.
I'm feel like,
I feel like you can't really,
you don't feel like a performer up there.
Yeah.
I'll feel soft.
I have to ask you this.
All of these roasts and it's so fucking hard to run away.
Last six,
sorry,
one last thing about that.
Just as far as food and my shows go.
Yeah,
you guys will appreciate this work in the road.
I still hold the Tempe Improv record for food sales.
I have the fattest fans.
Really.
I do appreciate that.
Sorry you guys.
No disrespect to Ralphie.
May he rest in peace?
Who,
uh,
sold the most tater tots in a weekend there?
They told me once,
but I sold the most food sales.
You shouldn't need to do part of that back end.
You're going to have to renegotiate.
Oh,
we're all good.
Don't worry.
Tempe.
They let me have a three hamburgers to go that night.
Oh Wow.
Wow.
My back end is fine.
Okay,
good deal.
My front end.
It's getting a little fat.
Um,
but anyway,
I was going to ask you about writing roast jokes.
I mean did that,
so it's just the hardest,
especially because you're like the big dog in that,
you know what I mean?
You're the guy that comes up with the real zingers.
So how do you fucking do the thing?
How do you know to write the joke that no one's going to fucking do you?
Like how do you do it?
Yeah,
you're the big dog.
What do you mean?
Okay.
Uh,
Pamela Anderson's on whatever,
right.
Let your fucking big tits,
your pussy,
this and that.
You know what?
They're going to go after.
Let them go after it.
You got to have a better joke.
You just have to have the best joke.
Well,
everybody else has a rough draft.
You got to have a joke that they are not going to think
so.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
So how do you get to the joke that no one's going to think of?
Do you write all the obvious ones first and then just throw them in the trash?
Yeah.
Really.
You do that
more often than not.
When I first here who were roasting,
they go,
what do you think we're going to roast?
You know what a Bruce Willis,
I already have a great thinking punchlines.
And the first thing I think of usually becomes a great opening joke or closing
thought.
Really?
It's your first Bruce Willis Thought,
oh,
uh,
I was like,
oh,
that's it.
You know,
it's going to have to be something about,
um,
how I look like him would be uneasy one,
but you know,
die hard.
Um,
whatever eight,
um,
natural causes,
you know,
and then,
so people will have die hard jokes.
So you gotta you gotta you gotta try harder and yeah.
And,
and I started to look at what other connections there are like,
oh,
okay.
We're both from New Jersey.
There's something I can work with.
Even your promos for that one.
We're great.
Thanks.
Yeah,
you guys do,
you guys did them together?
Yeah.
We're like,
you did,
you parodied,
um,
what's it called?
That movie the sixth sense.
It's sense I see dead people and it was all,
I see fat people and he said it to me.
I was a kid in the bed.
Yeah.
That's really fun.
They're really funny.
I got to repost those for,
for uh,
a throwback cause those were fun promos.
I got to work basically act with Bruce Willis for one full day.
It's awesome.
And by the way,
never met a greater sport.
Right.
He was calling me for a month and a half before the roast.
I stutter,
make fun of this.
Don't hold back because I want to have all the goodwill when I go up at the end.
And you know,
he loved it.
He really loved it.
That's cool.
That's good to hear actually.
Yeah,
he sent me a bunch of stuff.
Wrote me a nice letter.
A good guy.
Yeah.
That's cool.
Now you finally have joined the podcast.
Yeah.
So a tough skin,
thick skin,
skin,
thick skin with Jeff Ross.
I always say life is hard.
We're getting through it together.
It's a cathartic bonding experience.
How many are up so far?
Um,
we just went with probably have about 10 episodes up.
Sometimes I take down the old ones just because I don't know why.
I like having just a few up.
Oh really?
I like having the new ones,
the newer ones up pit people.
We'll go deep on that back catalog.
I know,
but for some reason I don't want him to,
I like,
I like keeping them fresh.
I don't know why.
I think it's still like a hobby level for me,
but I was out on the road one weekend when I first moved to my new house in
studio city in the hills up there and my cousin Ed who loves podcast and he just
built a little studio down under the under the house and the pool and I really,
really enjoying it.
It takes me back to my college radio days.
Yeah,
we had Larry Charles on last week.
He directed the boar APP movies,
movies that it's amazing.
The dangerous world of comedy,
a dangerous World Academy,
a really cool show showing people doing stand up and like Pakistan and Syria and
Saudi Arabia and he's just a cool guy.
So yeah,
like this and you,
you guys get it.
You've been doing it for a long time.
I'm really love it.
I always resisted because it's a discipline and you told me,
Tom,
you told me in the hallway the other day at the comedy store,
like you got to stay consistent.
You've got to keep doing it.
So I'm,
I have been getting better at consistently doing it because that's what the
listeners,
they want to rely on.
You a little Philly.
They definitely do.
Yeah.
You're a natural for it.
It's going to be great man.
Thanks.
Yeah,
just keep at it.
Keep,
keep doing it.
I really do.
The hard part is asking people to do it.
I woke up today with that dilemma of like for us,
what are you talking about?
I know,
but you know,
some people just,
I just know how I feel when certain people ask me to do it and I'm like,
oh,
how do you say no?
Then you're there reluctantly and then you wind up doing it and then you have a
good time and you're like,
all right,
well I'm glad I did it.
But you take advantage of the fact that you're Jeff fucking Ross.
I liked that.
Yeah,
I did notice that people started stopping me and asking me if they could come
out.
Oh,
that's a good sign.
Must Be.
And it's growing and you do it like a,
like a little roast at the end of the episode.
And we do like touchy subjects on the news,
you know,
whenever somebody dies,
it's a very cathartic,
when someone dies,
we do roast in peace.
You know,
we torque class week.
Who from the monkeys then you do one of a,
a Brodie.
We did a Brody one give us a Brody.
I said a poor Brody.
He's,
I'm seeing in that big side stage and the sky now
it says something about his great friendship with Zach Galifianakis.
If they ever hugged,
there'd be like velcro.
They would never be able to separate then.
They're both.
So Harry,
his hairline is named after his high school received a
funny,
we did the Brodie thing yesterday and now here I am.
I think that this might be my first time in receipt.
Yeah.
So there you go.
There you go.
Brody made it happen.
He really did.
I'm sensing as positive energy.
Um,
course I wanted to show you.
any other advice for the podcast?
This is helpful.
No,
I gotcha.
I think assistance.
I think the consistency.
I think how you've been doing this 10 years.
Beautiful.
I think you put in,
you definitely will like you,
first of all,
you created like a little bit of a specific thing going on,
which is good.
Yeah.
You know,
there's so many.
So the fact that it's like,
I think that you're the roast guy,
people know that.
Yeah.
And you at least give an element of that.
Right.
But not entirely.
It's not the whole thing.
It's more about taking the jokes then dishing them out the podcast,
like thick skin,
like you know,
a little bit of like I always say life is hard.
We're getting through it together.
Yeah.
Well here's the thing too about like feeling weird about asking people if,
because it like it matters that you're doing it,
then use whatever juice you have to get any and all guests because it's a guest
reliant medium.
So you know,
don't ever feel weird about asking anybody.
Not that you should,
but I mean the fact that you mentioned that like,
you know,
you deserve to have those guests.
Yeah.
It's going to be a better product.
So ask everyone,
man.
Thanks.
Yeah.
What about not having guests sometimes like,
oh,
it's great sometimes.
Right?
I like it sometimes if it's just me and my cousin talking to that.
And you sprinkle those in.
Yeah,
like I sometimes I forget that it's on the draw to this show you got,
it's like when David Letterman would come out or Jimmy,
you know,
Jimmy Kimmel or Jimmy Fallon walk out on stage,
they don't bring Julia Roberts out.
Right.
They do 10 15 minutes of comedy.
People tune in for,
yes.
Yeah.
No,
we do.
We do.
The front part of our show is just us.
All the grants and stuff.
I think it's important to do that and just and the,
and like 10 and do the episodes.
I joke,
I meant what's good.
Oh yeah.
I hope I'm,
I hope I'm at least as a better guest than Danny Brown.
What?
Danny was amazing.
I know he's your best guest ever.
So I thought it makes sense.
That's good.
That's funny.
He was,
yes.
Yeah,
he uh,
he came in here with like all the references were like,
what the,
he's like,
I listen to this shit all the time.
Like I was like,
oh my God.
I know.
That's so bizarre.
Cause like rappers listened to podcasts.
So we've had this thing of rappers coming on our show.
There's the crossover now.
Yeah,
sure.
Music and comedy are really colliding in a big way right now.
Yeah.
Well I went bumping Mike's came out of sort of getting all these messages from
musicians.
Really.
Drake,
Drake hardest I ever laughed.
DMD May don't even barely know.
The guy who just found me on Instagram.
Loved it.
It was crazy.
I know.
It's really been fun.
Really Been Fun.
Yes.
I ask
you something,
you said that a roasting was anti bullying,
which I think is,
I 100% agree with you,
but in this current bullshit,
social justice warrior culture,
I feel like people mistaken busting chops are busting balls for like not having
sympathy a particular group.
It's like,
dude,
why can't I have sympathy for somebody and make a joke about them at the same
time?
Like,
do you find that you're bumping up against people being fucking pussies about
this stuff?
Well,
or just upset about everything?
You know,
I'm offended by people that are constantly offended.
Yeah.
It's wearing me out.
It's like everything.
If it's a new language now I quit my job.
I was so humiliated,
you know,
toughen up.
I mean,
Jesus lifestyle.
Yeah.
So,
you know,
I had a rough childhood.
It's not as bad as some of the ones that I wasn't separated from my parents at
the border.
Yeah.
But you know,
my parents were sick and they died when I was a teenager.
And I go,
I think that gave me thick skin to talk about morning and moving on.
And how did you know,
he think kids didn't tease me.
And it's like,
you know,
jokes and you gotta be able to like handle your business or what are you,
what are you doing?
You're just worried,
you know,
social media has made that more of a,
of a thing right now.
But you know,
I just,
I'm,
I'm not into the wimpy pussy culture,
meaning either,
you know,
women,
women are equals women should need to be able to be part of the labs and
disabled people need to be part of the,
be able to take a joke and,
and,
and every ethnicity needs to be able to take the joke.
And I find no two of the people listening to my podcasts,
those are the people coming to our show.
Most fun people at shows.
Oh my God.
When you're listing the best audience.
Yeah,
I've heard that the fucking best.
Cause they've been through some shit.
Yeah.
Rich boss told me that there's a great one.
Fucking gay dudes are the best here in the valley.
Uh,
that Guy Bang court run.
Yes.
That's a jam at a show.
We would,
we'd do it like once every six months.
I did it a couple times,
man.
So game there.
Sounds cool.
Yeah.
More like,
yeah,
it's fun to perform for people that are paying and of course we need to do that
and,
and we appreciate our fans,
but when I go to like a jail or,
or,
you know,
I've done shows for the homeless.
I've done shows for,
you know,
in war zones.
Those are them.
That's crowd.
Yeah.
They're not paying,
they're not drinking.
They're there because they need it.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's medicine.
You've gone abroad.
You don't want your medicine water down either.
You want a potent,
yeah,
bro.
You've done the war zone shit a lot,
right?
Yeah.
That's wild.
That's a really,
really,
I do.
I did get mo once.
That was cool.
She did.
What year was that?
Do you remember?
Get Mo?
Yeah.
Oh nine yeah,
I did that.
No,
five.
It was really,
that was maybe the best show I've ever had in my life.
Yeah,
there was,
they were great.
Shows are just so star for these marines
and Navy and so on to live on one Tottenham obey base,
naval base,
you know,
and obviously there's a whole stigma in a dark cloud of of Guantanamo Bay.
The terrorists are there and the torture and,
but there's also a whole other gigantic military community.
Even part of the prison yeah.
Was most of it's not right.
Yeah.
And as you know,
those,
those are great crowds and Oh yeah,
there's families living in there and it's like the military shows up in gray
because I got to see stuff that normal people don't get to see.
And I,
I really dig that.
Did she go to Afghanistan?
I've been there.
Yeah,
I did that to you.
You slept with the whole seal team,
right?
Didn't you hook up with everybody in the seal teams?
Teams six,
that's all they got the nickname [inaudible] sex.
Did you ever do,
there's an oil platform in the middle of the fucking ocean between Iran and
Iraq.
There's like an a mile long oil platforms and they fly.
Have you ever done that one play out?
That was crazy.
And half of it's US marine.
Half of it's I'm Iraqi soldiers Thursday and they butt fuck each other on a
platform.
And you got,
they showed me the fuck mattresses and stuff and I just sleep with like guards
outside of my,
um,
you know,
it's not a room.
It's those,
those metal,
what do they call those metal boxes?
They have them everywhere,
like in Djibouti and shit in the marriage.
Like if you're in a war zone,
just have fun,
you know?
Yeah.
I get it.
You never know.
Iraqi soldiers,
the war zone becomes a horror zone.
Hey God,
that's great that you do.
That's great that you do that and that's,
I love you.
A woman comedian in a war zone.
Like it's so rare.
It was nuts.
I did Afghanistan,
I did Saudi Arabia.
I even got to go in to do Riyadh based there.
I was fucking nuts.
The UAE,
I would never do it again.
Djibouti Malia,
It's so dangerous.
Worst place I've ever been worse.
Yeah.
It was like 140 degrees or so.
Fucking high ze your hand.
Yeah.
It was terrifying.
Terrible there for one long day.
Stop over in the Middle East,
the Middle East.
And I was there with the chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff General Richard
Myers at the time and oh five and they call it the chairman's tour where he's,
he stops,
you know,
during the holidays and like eight or nine countries and some of them are safe
and some of them aren't.
But he even walked up on stage and Djibouti and was like,
hey man,
you guys,
hat's off to you,
your station in the worst place.
We have
worse.
He was very upfront about it.
There was no getting around.
I know.
This sucks.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
And then we,
and we had just been to Iraq,
so like he's really laying it down there.
Yeah.
I never did Iraq.
I've been to,
um,
well I said uh,
Afghanistan,
Iraq
cause genuinely fascinating and terrifying.
I've been here three times.
It's no different in an o three than it is two years ago when I was there or
where you go back to war zones.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I went,
I went two Christmases ago.
I guess,
and sadly will,
I'll have to keep going because it doesn't sound like any of that ends ending in
my lifetime.
Be Nice if all those Saddam palaces were casinos by now.
Yeah.
I think Trump would have made that happen.
Right,
right.
But no,
no.
You know who I went with Sarah Tiana,
right near a homey.
It,
she's the best.
She's the best.
Oh.
And I did,
uh,
did a,
um,
some USO stuff together too.
We went to,
um,
Germany to Lanch Landstuhl Medical Hospital did a show.
She's the sweetest,
she's a killer.
He's a killer.
Keller talented.
And she really gets it.
I remember we were touring these bases and she was just,
her heart went out to all,
like,
I was such a selfish kind of dig.
I was complaining that it's hot and the food's not good.
And Sarah was just like,
that's not why we're here.
Christina.
You know,
like,
she's so mature,
so smart.
She's just something special about her.
Yeah.
She,
she's a really incredible person and a great writer,
great comedian,
great friend.
She was bawling last night.
Right in the front row at the Brody.
Yeah,
no,
yeah,
we work together with Brody on the burn on comedy central.
Sarah was one of the writers and Brody was there,
a warm up guy and it was a real family for 12 episodes.
That's show business,
you know,
the shows come and go.
I always think like the shows,
the projects,
the pilots,
they come and go,
but these relationships are what sustain us.
Yeah.
You know,
you're talking about talking to me years ago before we even knew each other.
We had a relationship.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
it's like when you're on stage and there's that intensity and he went into
another guy in a strange town and he's pacing and he's nervous.
Oh,
am I going to make it harder for them or worse for him?
It's like side,
you know?
Who are you?
I just had a flashback to another one of talking to you.
Oh,
I did the Melrose Improv and uh,
you know,
I was booked on the show.
It must have been like,
oh
six or seven.
And I had,
I had a great set,
like a great set and you were on the show and then,
you know,
people kind of gather afterwards,
outside out front.
And I just like stood next to you and,
and uh,
you're talking to other people and other comics and I just like just like stood
kinda like waiting and then you looked at me and you're like,
you got a great set.
That was hilarious.
I was like,
thanks man.
And then I just kept staring at you.
Wow.
Yeah.
What was going on there?
I just wanted to like,
yeah,
I just want it to like be part of the group.
Wow.
You know what I mean?
So I think,
yeah,
I think I probably freaked you out at a certain point.
I definitely saw you look at me like,
all right man.
Yeah.
And there's no way I watched your set,
so I was just Kinda Nice.
Yeah,
I definitely was like,
I can remember vividly standing out there.
Well,
I've found this to be nice because now looking at we're friends.
I felt like I'm the queen of Showbiz when one time Sarah town,
I took me into your house for a barbecue like a decade ago and I was like,
oh my God.
Right Jeff Ross or were you like,
oh we're,
this is just like a war zone.
Everything goes suck all these dicks.
Yeah.
Much Barbecue Dick.
Um,
since we were,
by the way,
since Christina's far,
it was so disappointing.
Darya,
can you pull up,
there's a,
we haven't seen seen this yet,
but this is supposed to be the check that's going to make you really,
sorry,
I thought I had a fire,
but watch this.
Okay.
Watch.
Watch this.
This is,
but you were setting up something else.
Give me a sec.
Oh,
oh,
whatever you have.
Oh,
then you say that we had to watch these.
Okay.
No.
Well,
uh,
there's a,
there's a ranking of girls that we've seen.
The new one.
Oh,
I see.
Okay.
So let's see who we've seen.
That's what you have here.
Okay.
Who is your fave?
Jeff,
you are?
No,
no,
no.
Move part of us.
Oh,
sorry.
Hold on minute.
I'm interrupting.
Or Oh,
I like,
I like when they get playful with you.
Yeah.
Like what are the grounds for,
oh,
what the fuck?
We watch it.
Growth rubbing and bananas on her ass on calling in the SPANDEX.
What?
What had happened?
She smells,
I had stayed home with my housekeeper.
Elvia I've seen that
covered that.
We covered this girl in episode.
Uh,
for 12.
Really?
It,
I don't remember this.
A whole bunch of things.
Renames them with Fart in the word.
Okay.
No,
I,
no,
I know you've been doing this podcast.
This is your,
this is how you get your material.
It's pretty easy.
Oh yes.
Crazy Barrow.
Keep that part in mind.
Okay.
We're now going,
are we rating them?
I think so.
Yeah.
We're ranking these here.
The next part.
Nana.
Nana,
Oh,
okay.
I remember her.
I'm in the shed.
Yeah.
There's a reason.
She's pretty cute.
I like the shed farts.
Yeah.
Well girls do that.
I never saw a girl do that before with like the reverb.
Kind of like the base.
I didn't have no girl Fargo though.
Right now
I know what I like about that far fart.
I will say Tommy,
I feel like there was heat to it.
I feel like she had apricot's like those trader Joe's ones.
Why can't I get ready to re rank everything new champ.
I remember this vividly.
This is really intense.
Not even
reacting.
She didn't miss a beat on that book either.
I love the name for that.
Yeah,
this day.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
There's always part for you guys.
She makes you like it.
It's a late Ballantine fart.
Please come and download.
Subscribe and let me know what you're thinking about.
My fart.
Give me a thumbs up.
You guys ready?
Okay,
here we go.
I'm ready.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
That was the best part ever.
No,
that was,
it wasn't that people post on Youtube.
Oh,
everywhere.
Sometimes they are on pay sites.
Really a lot of guys will pay to watch women fart.
Really?
Yeah.
What do you think that is?
The one guy who wrote in about it is that he,
he said that the reason he has a fetish for it is because it's like the taboo
thing to see a pretty girl having like a dirty smell,
you know?
And what about this one that's different?
She's,
yeah,
she's just,
that's just her skill.
Not that she's bad looking,
but I don't think of her as a,
no,
I think you were typically pretty girl laying in bed in the tee shirt going on
here.
My alarm.
I think your instincts are dead on.
I see your point.
So what you're trying to say is there was no,
there was no set up to this one.
It wasn't as creative as the fart.
Nana
whale.
A blowhole
Gotcha.
Yeah.
A little hard on the eyes.
Oh,
this is all set up.
I like that one.
Ooh.
Mop on aisle five.
What's the fucking on her belt there?
She's got like a hike.
One of those climbing hooks?
Yeah,
like carabiners.
That's what that's called.
Yeah.
Okay.
Now what's this in the porn genre?
When they do it out in the wild.
What's that called in the porn,
John?
I don't know.
I don't know what that's called.
Face not a face fart when you make porn out and like on public,
public public.
This is a public park.
Voyeurism.
[inaudible] something like that.
Josh,
Josh
subscribes,
all of these.
So this was a public fart.
That was really interesting.
What are those are,
those are all five parts.
I mean,
which one was your favorite one?
Well,
let's go through and cheesy.
Well yeah,
the lady who was reading the book.
No,
no bananas.
Yeah.
Come on.
Yeah,
it cause it's part Anna's,
yeah,
I just love bananas.
My grandpa used to say take a banana for the ride.
Okay.
Those early.
Uh,
I mean I just love bananas and they're good.
Bright.
Before you go on stage [inaudible] or no,
I don't think I would eat the fart bananas.
Bananas.
I don't think I really get
what she's doing there.
I think she's going to throw those away or just saved them.
But I think she's saving quite a bit about if she peeled it Neda down.
There's a guy that does that,
but I dunno if you want to see that.
I I'm going to,
I don't like shed fart because that was just very generic.
It was like,
yeah,
I'm going to shed.
Yeah.
I mean,
yeah,
I'm in the shed,
but why?
There's a reason.
What's the reason you have to go in the shed the fart.
That doesn't make sense,
Huh?
Pardon the shit?
Yeah,
but why this you?
She has a fart shed.
Yeah.
Like she has her own shed for four.
Well,
she's not going to fall on her podcast.
We'll do that material.
She went out to the shed like a lady.
Right?
Right.
So,
wait,
is there a new person?
Is that what you're saying?
Yeah,
there is.
Why don't you guys discuss who gets ranked number one,
two and three and I'll pull up this new foreign minister.
Okay.
I can't believe I'm going to go for him personally.
I don't think the shed fart was that exciting.
I'm going to give her fifth place.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Do you guys agree with this ranking?
Yeah.
Last place.
Nothing for me.
For me.
It's all about the book lady Breely.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
What?
What are you going to give her first place?
Oh yeah.
For me,
she's seriously for sure.
Why?
I mean,
just the,
like the way that it was so dominant and,
and like there was so much muscle behind it and the way she was so nonchalant,
like,
gosh,
it just shouldn't even look up from the book.
Oh yeah.
It's really owned it,
you know?
All right.
I'll just disagree.
I've filled the sponsor to show toilet paper.
Used to be Mcdonald's,
but they left,
so
I liked the public farter because it's a brave,
it's bold.
Oh,
right.
It's risky.
That took nerve a little bit in the supermarket.
Yeah.
Yeah,
a little bit,
but it wasn't,
I liked the bananas on strictly on the performance art of it all.
Yeah.
The performance part of it all.
The performance artist.
Yeah.
I'm going to,
I'm torn between the Fart Nana and the Valentine for it.
I liked the Valentine premise.
She's like,
hey guys,
as a felon times day and here's a fart that was on this,
that one time for it.
Yeah.
Right here in your heart.
Here's a valentines.
Oh yeah.
It was Kinda Nice that she gave you the gift and I liked that she plugs her
channel.
So scribe line,
right.
She puts the plug out and then
delivers.
Yeah.
I just didn't feel like the delivery was there.
Who's this?
This is our new person.
This is the new girl.
And uh,
when I saw it,
I knew we had something special.
Okay.
These make me so gassy.
Right?
These are what my farts are going to smell it.
Oh my God.
I don't know what I like more than what she's doing or watching Jeff watcher.
I don't know if she's farting or belching.
I love this.
Whoa.
I didn't get it.
Uh,
hey man.
What's going on?
Exactly.
It's like around us.
This seems like it's in the
gluttonous.
This is the queen ass rubber.
I didn't know Steve's got a wig.
This is pretty wild,
man.
That's the belly button.
Looks like an ass climbing on me the road.
Oh,
okay.
This is a little much.
Okay.
She's trying too hard.
Yeah.
We haven't even gotten to the phone trying to heart.
This girl has talent.
This is really good.
Okay.
I don't know if I can,
I'm in love.
I think I'm going to gay.
Married her.
I love this check.
I am blown away by this talent.
Listen,
king ass ripper was amazing.
This chick kicks his ass.
You think so dude?
Can you ask her is nothing
right?
This is,
I don't know.
To be fair to be first.
Not to be fair.
This is a trans woman.
Wait a minute.
Pipe.
I Dunno.
I think it is.
Am I right?
Okay.
Do you think it's transforming?
I think you're onto something.
Yeah.
Shit man.
Listen,
without some of the original piping.
Is there trans fats?
You mean
fucking look at that big cushy,
yeah.
Can I have some?
You're watering email that I want to have a big butt,
but it's definitely a gassy one.
Okay.
We're good.
Oh yeah,
it's working.
I want to hear the farm.
I just think it's great than Andy.
Mellanox has a youtube page.
Oh my God,
Dude.
I'm impressed.
I mean,
is it true?
Is it,
is she trans?
Yeah.
Blue Band.
Is it confirmed?
I think she is.
I mean,
looking at the definition of the yards,
I think it's a possibility.
Hmm.
Hate.
No.
Uh,
have you been to Israel before?
Yes.
Did you perform there?
It's quite a segue.
I know
you're asking me about how the farting is over there.
What was it like?
Did you find a lot of Mediterranean food will kind of go through Oh,
the Shwarma uh,
yeah.
I,
I've been,
I performed there twice,
most recently.
Um,
uh,
just a year ago with Chris Rock,
I was a surprise guest on his Telaviv show that show ever,
ever update with my get Moesha seriously the best.
What was it like doing rocks tour?
I loved every second of it.
I love spending time with Chris.
Um,
I would do,
he would have me go on right before him and,
and do my standup and then bring
up,
and these are huge arenas.
10,
15,000,
and I'd work it out with security where I'd bring up volunteers from the front
sections,
line them up to speed,
roast the shit out of him in arena style Copenhagen,
Stockholm.
All through Ireland and England and man,
you know,
as it was,
it was amazing experience in all these foreign countries and we,
we made a stop and Tel Aviv and you know,
people just,
American comedy is,
is a great at our biggest export and one of our biggest exports.
Yeah,
everyone's down.
What we were doing,
what I was saying and even though I wouldn't understand all the accents and
Sweden,
they got everything we said and it was like,
it was a really great experience.
You had to like nothing.
Same,
same act I do here,
except they're more eager to hear about Trump and politics and what our take is
was on it.
And they,
they all know Christmas specials from over the years.
I learned how to speak English.
A lot of people listening to Chris Rock and Eddie Murphy and wow.
And that kind of stuff.
Wild.
It was really,
really cool.
And that was the tour that ended up being the tambourine right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
It's been really fun.
Probably gonna ramp up again,
I think in another year or so he'll start thinking about it again because it's
just,
it's too juicy.
Yeah.
Lots of people want to see him in every corner of the world.
There's places he still hasn't gone.
Yeah.
He put the act together in a year and he tours her for a year.
It's amazing.
And he's sent me,
sent me a,
a three wheeled motorcycle as a present.
Why?
I almost drove it here and just learning how to drive it.
Cause the stick.
But it's,
it's incredible.
Awesome thing.
I would never buy myself.
Really?
Yeah.
It's a motorcycle.
It's a three wheeled motorcycle.
It's called a slingshot.
Oh,
I've seen those really fun.
That's manual.
Yeah.
Oh,
I got to see this thing.
I'll show you a picture after.
Okay.
Well this guy,
is this an Israel?
Um,
the guy talking to him is definitely Israeli.
Okay.
100% sure if this is Israel.
It looks like it might.
Yeah.
And you're saying this guy puts on quite a show that we're watching?
He actually reminds me of someone that we used to have on the show.
Okay.
Let's see.
Hi,
Ms. Dot.
Malik food
are a little spot I'm going to kill.
Wait,
wait.
I'll go on.
Pay Half the bomb.
So this is an Elvis impersonator,
I think.
I love foreigners doing stupid shit,
man.
You know,
one time in Hungary,
my parents are from Hungary and we went to go see some stupid lounge act and the
mill of,
anyway,
they see,
they don't know.
They can't speak English fluently and it was the sun.
Oh,
zinc device
is another day for you in Paris.
Like they couldn't say the words and the style.
Laughing so fucking hard.
I love when foreigners can't just staying alive guy.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Do you have stay United State United State.
You will not stay United.
Stay United.
Yeah.
I love this kind of shit.
Yeah,
this is damn it.
This guy would probably impress Jeff.
Oh my goodness.
They United States United stand.
You know
that you've been knocking guys felt even uh,
uh,
you're weighting based data.
Bitch did it.
We made it.
Now,
why is daddy and I went dead,
I suppose are the words.
So I'm by no,
no,
I go and buy shows.
So you're not as you United that your name is [inaudible].
Oh Wow.
Would you,
would he be hard to roast or no?
He seems rough.
Stubble.
Yeah.
He looks like he's already been roasted.
Wow.
By far,
the most fun I've ever had watching someone's watch clips on this show has been
Jeff Ross.
I would love to play tic tac toe on his forehead and what is going on his teeth
look like Stonehenge
that's going on with this guy,
but yet remarkably fashionable penny and,
and aviators.
Yeah.
And might even have hair plugs this guy,
but yet never put sunscreen on at once in his life and never been to a dentist.
The nearest tennis is 10,000 miles away.
He's Moroccan.
Yeah.
That's where he fell.
I see a lot of outdoor time.
Always gets his son.
Oh
Jesus.
Okay.
Um,
I like,
Elvis is something that he knows is on the Internet and think he knows he's on
your podcast.
I don't know if he knows me out of the pocket.
But after we found that video,
people started to send in other videos.
Okay.
So he makes videos and posts some of them singing?
No,
I think he allows people to film him.
Oh.
And in like public places.
Um,
and then,
you know,
cause there's,
I think he's in Spain now,
right?
Yeah,
he's on tour
in Morocco or something.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Um,
he should have a show called [inaudible] skin.
No,
me.
Him.
I would love to have him on.
He would just do stay alive over and over though.
Huh?
Hey.
You'd be like,
yeah,
we got it.
We got it.
Wait,
so we'll bump in.
Mike's come back.
We're going to do a tour this summer,
May and June.
Oh you are?
Yeah.
We'll be at the more God,
I will be at the sands and Bethlehem and then we're picking up some more dates
soon as I can get Dave to agree.
Is that,
that's the work of it,
right?
Oh so hard.
He's got,
you know,
tornadoes himself all the time.
He doesn't want to split the money.
There's,
I want to go to Florida.
Like there's a lot of rules.
It doesn't go anywhere where he has his family really smart.
He won't wants to avoid it.
He wants to go to casinos in the Midwest and south and North Pacific where he
doesn't know anybody where they let them smoke in the elevators.
He's still ripping through cigarettes.
Right?
Yeah.
I love Dave,
but it's like taking your Nana on the road.
He's,
he's cranky dude.
What was that line?
Uh,
so funny.
It's,
I think it's in the first episode.
I can say it right.
So please,
you're like,
you look like somebody who knows how to delete a hard drive.
[inaudible] it looks like he knows how to delete a hard drive in a hurry.
I think I said
it's a challenge coming up with insults for David Tell because he wears the same
thing every single show.
Whereas I mix it up and give him some something to work with.
I'll where I had a different shirt,
different shoes and coat.
I saw him at a show like a month ago.
I saw him backstage and he was wearing the same thing.
And I was like,
how's the manifesto coming along?
It's good.
That's great.
Yeah.
He's a good guy.
He got a good heart.
Yeah.
He raises my game.
I love,
I love working with them.
I'm going to happen for the two of you.
I mean the two of you working together,
it's,
I mean I,
I tell Dave all the time.
One plus one is three.
You know,
we're,
we're great on our own.
He's the best on its own,
but when we come together it pops too.
Another thing,
it's like a band.
Yeah.
Joe Walsh join the eagles.
I would buy a ticket to go see the shit.
Oh that's great.
Keep an eye out for you coming to see you too.
I hope you guys do another.
Probably should have toured right when the thing came out.
We didn't,
we both just stopped.
We needed a break from each other.
I think,
you know what?
The way that Netflix specials work,
the biggest bump comes like nine months after.
I'm really cause it,
it builds and it builds and it builds and like there's people this week who are
discovering that's never heard of it.
Seeing it right now really on top of all the people that saw it before.
I don't think it dies down now.
I know when you announced these tickets they'll go way faster than they did last
time for sure.
That's nice to hear.
Yeah,
that'll be good.
Yeah.
You'll,
you'll do some added shows and markets you weren't expecting is definitely going
to be different,
Huh?
Yeah.
Even in the casino markets you think cause that was a really,
he won't really do that.
Theaters,
he likes to casinos.
What's the deal?
Why the casino they pay better.
He could smoke and the ad,
here's the other thing,
you'll get a raise here.
You'll get a raise in all of those.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
So whatever you did last time it's going to go up for sure.
I love it.
And I've been,
I've been using this time away from him to work on material so that when we join
back up in May and June and stuff,
like I can bring some fire power too because he's on the road constantly.
Yeah.
So I've just been popping up at the comedy store and the Improv and I'm in Bray
in a couple of weeks like just to work on material because trying to keep up
with Dave,
Dave's the best comic there is right now.
And the fact that he lets me do these shows with him like blows my mind.
So the last thing I want to do is just ask him questions and be his fall guy.
Like I want to bring it to and have some good material and you know,
he gets squeamish or by talking about a political joke or you know,
but it forces him to then like retort with another political jokes.
So it's no way we have,
we challenge each other in a really interesting way.
Oh you guys are just so good.
You have such good chemistry,
chemistry,
very complimentary.
And it looks like you guys are just,
you know,
it's a beautiful tennis thing to watch back and forth.
I have a technical question.
I love your technical questions.
Fun.
Interesting how you guys,
so I know
if only you could use this stuff on your active workout crib.
That's roasting by listening.
Yeah,
you did it.
You did it.
Um
Oh.
I was like,
okay.
See you.
You only have one show to tape,
right?
You can't obviously have the same audience for two cause you were doing it in
clubs.
The button
we did,
we did three nights at the comedy village underground at the comedy cellar.
We did two shows a night.
Different obviously different audiences and all that.
Yeah,
mostly different.
We get a lot of repeats as you can imagine because there's so much improvising.
He's improvising that they want us,
they want to see more.
They just don't want to leave.
You know,
Paul Rudd is in the Sunday episode of bumping rights on Netflix.
The only reason he closes the second show with us is because he was there with
his wife and friends for the first show.
Loved it so much called the babysitter,
almost like we're staying out and stayed for a whole other show.
And by then I was like,
all right,
this guy's had a bunch of drinks.
He's here for two shows.
I'm not even going to ask him or just bringing them up.
Yeah.
And he's flew right out of his seat and played with us for 10 minutes.
So it is a night out.
Like we produce it by not really completely producing it.
We kind of put a few things out there like,
like Bruce Willis said,
hey,
I want to come see your show.
I said,
great.
You know,
take care of you and your friend.
Put him on the gas was,
I don't see him before.
I don't tell him I'm going to introduce him.
I wouldn't have introduced them,
but Dave was like,
all right,
I'll take it,
you know,
and he just like shouting them out.
So I said to myself that afternoon and Bruce Willis was coming,
we're shooting.
It's our first night.
What if something does happen where he leaps out of his chair or something does
happen.
I want to be prepared.
I don't really want to write the jokes about them,
but maybe if I had a harmonic in my back pocket just in case something cool will
happen.
And that's as much as take the producing of it,
like yeah.
Kind of what ifs and maybes and prepare for different things.
And literally Dave and I don't speak before the show.
He won't make a set list.
You won't block,
he won't rehearse,
just no makeup.
He,
he is off to street,
you know,
has a cigarette.
He'll say hi and we go and if I wanna like,
hey Dave,
we set me up for this,
this and this.
And I'm really,
oh no,
it's infuriating.
And sometimes,
and sometimes I'll set them up for a joke that he's done three nights in a row
and knocked out of the park and then he'll,
he'll,
he'll just ignore me.
And that's infuriating.
Oh yeah.
And that's,
so,
by the way,
it's definitely so it's repeating them because I,
I,
I've told this story before,
like site,
I worked with him years ago.
I opened for forum,
like I middled for him a few times and I was like,
so you know,
so geek,
this is like insomnia is on,
you know,
right.
Like just it's everywhere and every comic coming up you're like,
oh my God,
I love this guy.
Right.
He's and you know,
all the shows are packed.
He is fucking destroying.
Yeah.
Was Bria?
Yeah,
I did.
I did two years apart,
two separate weekends with him,
like six show weekends and like,
you know,
so you do your Thursday show and you're like,
holy shit in Friday,
early show,
you know,
let's say most of that stuff.
And then on the late show it's the same setup and a different punch line.
You're like,
what the fuck did I mean?
Like,
and like the punchline killed and he's already like,
and then Saturday,
it's not the first one that killed,
it's not the second one,
that D it's another punchline right in there.
And I'm like,
well,
he finds what he likes and then when he gets it the way he likes it,
he never does it again.
Dates repeating himself.
He's not thinking about building material for a special,
he's just thinking about staying true to what he thinks is funny all the time.
All the time.
So if we happen to be shooting that weekend,
that's the jokes we get on tape.
That's really,
that's really how it is.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
He gets another half hour that he could have done,
but we'll also like argue about that.
I'm like,
Hey,
we got to like kill.
Like you've got to bring your best stuff.
And then I'll,
I'll set him up for a home run joke that's going to get us out of the episode
and he'll just ignore me.
It's infuriating.
And what about when you talk to him like afterwards about it?
He's,
like I said,
didn't feel like doing it mid.
He,
he won't even,
it's not even a proper question.
Really know that would even entertain the kid won't even know what I'm talking
about.
Yeah.
Wow.
I,
if I see them afterwards,
it's about the next show.
I don't have time to look back.
He's not engaging on that.
I've learned how not to fight with them and I learned that it's not me,
it's him and I become really patient.
And to be honest with you,
as much as we've been friends our whole careers,
Dave and I,
decades like I think this has us like truly how's,
where were we have a whole other respect for each other or,
and
I haven't really thought about this or talked about it too much,
but you know,
we had big fights going into this thing like a couple of years ago,
like a couple of Christmases ago when we were starting to,
like when I was pushing him to go to the Montreal comedy festival and let's call
it bumping Mike's and he didn't like that.
He didn't want to go to the festival.
There's no money.
He didn't want to call it bumping Mike's.
It was too on the nose.
He didn't want to.
And now we don't really fight.
We're sort of getting to a place where we kind of understand each other.
You're like an old married couple,
you and your Nana on the road.
Yeah.
You know how Nana is and I know how he is now and I don't push them on certain
things and he,
and he'll admit this too,
like he will,
um,
he will defer to me on other things were we would fight back about it all the
time,
you know,
and we're comics,
we end,
there's always little mood swings in here and there of course.
But finally one day I was like,
Dave,
just talk to me as nicely as you do the servers at the comedy cellar.
Cause he'll tips,
everybody brings him candy and then he'll look at me and go buy,
my mom would just bark at me about something.
I'm like,
no,
I don't need to get in to a messy marriage here,
bro.
You're like,
yeah,
we're to get along or we're not doing it.
You know.
And I'm always fascinated when two funny guys get together who don't necessarily
have to be together.
Right.
It's kind of fun.
Like when rappers get together,
I asked,
um,
there's a,
there's a musical thing called black star.
Talib Kweli is a rapper.
What most deaf and worse,
they both have solo careers and they do both do extremely well,
but they do the special thing together.
Blackstar.
Yeah.
And I asked to Lib Kweli I go,
how do you get along with most stuff?
Like how do you guys like work it?
And he goes,
oh,
I just do what most says.
I've learned that if I try to push back and,
and,
and you know,
most,
you know,
maybe I shouldn't be saying all this on the,
on the podcast,
but basically he said like,
he,
he's learned to just sort of trust that the other guy who was kinda right.
Yeah.
It's going to work and yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
I thought you were saying Yasiin Bey is a sovereign citizen,
so,
yeah.
Right.
It's going away.
That's my favorite thing ever is that most deaf was in Africa.
And he was like,
no,
I'm,
first of all,
I'm Yasiin Bey.
And then they're like,
you don't have a visa to be here.
And he was like,
I'm a sovereign citizen.
When they were like,
no,
that doesn't count.
Right.
You gotta get the Fuck Outta here,
man.
Yeah.
They kicked him out.
But those dudes are amazing together.
Yeah.
I've seen them together.
So you're saying that I'm that guy.
Yeah.
I think what Jeff is saying and you know,
in a marriage you realize there's just some fights that aren't worth having and
you trust and you know them and you know where you're,
I know or your abilities lie.
And I think you know our mind line,
there's just shit you don't fight about.
Cause you're like,
I know,
I know that Tom knows in this situation.
Like you know what's up here.
Yeah.
You trust choices too.
You're like
part of us doing it together.
Now we have,
you know,
Dave and I,
we met,
we got it,
we got through it and like he,
he pushes me to like,
he wasn't settling on a director and everybody I brought to him,
he either wouldn't meet with or they were too hip or they accused them of over
overlighting someone else's special,
you know,
he would be very persnickety about it.
Then I would get mad because he'd be being rude to people that,
you know,
are very respected.
And so Han and he wouldn't take the meeting or it'd be an hour late or whatever,
you know,
that's Dave.
And then,
you know,
I brought him finally.
I was
lamenting all this to my pal Andrew [inaudible] who is a documentarian.
Yeah.
And I knew I wanted this to have a documentary feel.
And Andrew and I kinda was like one in the morning.
We were just having one of our long walks were good pals.
Andrew directly directed,
uh,
the jinx on Hbo.
Unbelievable.
About Robert Durst.
It's unbelievable.
Yeah.
It's a fantastic multipart documentary.
So you know what bumping Mike's was going to be a three part documentary.
Actually,
Netflix wanted it to be more,
they wanted it to be like four in labor yesterday.
They was like,
no,
sorry.
I was like,
all right,
I can make that work Friday,
Saturday,
Sunday.
We'll make it a weekend.
Um,
format.
We'll call the episodes by the night and we'll see if that works.
And we'll do two shows a night and we'll intercut some of our sort of offstage
stuff.
And Andrew,
Eh,
Andrew,
to his credit,
even though he'd seen and I performed together many,
many times more than anyone else.
Andrew is not a comedy director.
He'd never worked in comedy.
And I'd been telling him for the whole 15 years I had been friends with this
guy,
you should do comedy.
It'll add years to your life.
These documentaries you keep doing about child molesters and murderers are a
drain on you and your family.
Fucking bummer.
Yeah,
right.
He did a,
you know,
the capturing the Friedman first big time ago about child molesters,
child molesters.
And I got in Long Island.
Yeah.
Genx I was obsessed with.
So it's so good.
And
Jews are very sophisticated filmmaker.
So I knew if I set up the comedy and the situation and got the club together
and,
and got the act together that Andrew would make it look good and he would also
be able to like maybe help me with some of,
yeah.
You know,
the friction between Dave and I.
Yeah.
And,
but we didn't want it to be like my friends directing it.
So Andrew went down to the comedy cellar without me and hung out with Dave and
they'd known each other a little bit,
threw me over the years and suddenly this,
this murder documentarian and Dave were getting along well and,
and Dave has these little tests that I don't,
I've never talked about this,
but you know,
like Amy Schumer,
Big Star was about to go on,
you know,
and Dave said,
I guess you want to go down and watch Amy and Andrew saw the trap.
Yeah.
He's like,
no,
I love Amy but I'm here to hang with you Dave.
And that's what they really,
you could tell they really fell in love.
Andrew told me this whole story after,
you know,
and uh,
you guys are playing chess man.
And that's what we really wanted to get Dave on board with Andrew because David
turned down three or four other comedy directors.
Wow.
Big,
big names.
Who would do that?
Who wanted to do it?
Guys winning Emmys for these things and stuff.
They was like,
Nah,
two,
two.
Yeah.
It's part of the lesson that you learned or what you figured out was like not to
be reactive to him reacting.
You kind of had to like take a breath and just allow him to be how he is.
Right.
And,
and,
and sort of not fault them for him.
And that's just who he is.
I have to love him for who he is and now he's starting to trust me.
And there were certain other things in the show and guests,
he didn't want that I really did force on him and he would immediately
afterwards say,
Yep,
you're right.
That was a good idea.
So I realize he was sort of the frosting a little bit themselves and you know,
other things I pushed him on,
he was adamant he didn't want to do and we didn't do it.
Yeah.
So there's a,
you know,
you pick your battles so to speak.
It's part of being,
I once asked,
I also once asked a Penn,
Penn Jillette who's in Penn and teller,
I said,
give me some advice,
give me some,
give me some advice.
Like,
how do you guys,
cause I written for a comedy team.
My first writing job was writing for MTV.
Read Johnny in the round,
guy to comics were,
this was in the 90s.
Uh,
John Dimaggio,
um,
uh,
from Futurama
was red Johnny.
And,
um,
Tim was his partner.
Um,
Tim Regan and,
and,
and I learned that they would always fight and I'd always be breaking up fights
between these guys.
I was like,
oh,
I can't have that with Dave.
And I had had these teams were,
and I remember Buddy Hackett telling me early on that they offered him to
replace one of the stooges in a movie when one of the stooges got sick.
Whoa.
And I needed the money.
I had just had my first kid.
I was still sort of a young comic,
not much of a following.
And I thought about it and I thought about it and I realize I don't want to wake
up every morning wondering how the other guy feels.
So I was like,
okay,
man,
now I'm in a team.
It sounds like such a bad idea.
I have the best life,
I'd do whatever I want now.
I got to like partner up and pens.
I asked pen and he's like,
he's like,
well no.
I go,
how does it work with you?
And tell her he goes,
well,
I mean,
no,
ours works because no other team has telled her as a partner.
In other words,
he loved teller
and they their special thing.
So it really is a unique look at u two.
I mean,
how many marriages work human married over a decade.
I know.
Most of the time these things are too,
they're too hot.
Where were where they're not sustainable
for us though.
And this probably helps other,
uh,
duos,
like especially the ones that only do that,
like we're not competitive things.
A big thing.
I remember talking to a couple married couples in comedy over the years who they
like lead with competitiveness.
Right?
I got this.
She didn't get that out of that.
They all their divorce.
All of them.
Yeah.
I think you're totally right.
And a lot of that because we're not,
we're not competitive because we started together and I think we did.
We did open mics together and we were in the trenches together for so many
years.
So your success is shared in a way.
Yeah.
It's like we are,
start a family together.
Yeah.
We're,
we're Cosby team.
Try Osby that's what we say.
It's from this old Cosby thing,
the word,
the word to mommy's one jeans,
like we share a pair.
That's just always been our mantra.
And truthfully what Penn said about a teller,
I adore him.
I fucking adore this man.
She always says it like the way I adore you.
I love your farts.
Even when you're disgusting.
Like I adore everything about you.
I do.
I think you're just adorable and I,
I don't know.
I will never not love him.
There's,
he can do no wrong.
Hmm.
I think that's part of it.
I'm just blinded by my affection for you.
That's maybe that's why I put up with Dave Shit because I am blinded by my
affection for them.
I really do
come on stage and I feel like I'm watching a folk hero or something.
Yeah.
He's such a good comic.
He really,
and,
and it's from my open mic days.
Yeah.
Like I,
I,
he was hosting the open mics when I was beginning.
He was already made,
he was already a couple of years in.
Um,
and I was always like,
I would,
I just want to watch them.
It was like,
he always had the best jokes.
He always had the newest jokes.
He always cut through.
He always trying something different.
And I have,
when I podcasted with him last,
I was like,
again,
like just,
you know,
in awe he's looking and he's like,
do you ever blink?
Like shit like that.
Where was this?
I was at a crushers house.
We all pass.
Got Your podcast at the,
and he just,
he doesn't do many.
The two of us were just like a couple of kids and just smiling at him and he was
just making fun of us for the entire time,
you know,
because we were like,
remember when you said this Joe?
He's like,
yeah,
of course.
I fucking remember.
Yeah.
He's so sharp.
And now that he doesn't drink,
he doesn't forget a thing.
He's,
he's very difficult to argue with because he can flip it back on you in a second
and mimic at the same time to just make you,
man,
I thought that,
oh,
we really like,
it wasn't my idea a year ago to ask him,
you know,
like
he doesn't forget a thing.
It's too funny.
And he said,
yeah,
he really,
uh,
Jess,
we were going to do an hour.
We're at 90.
Of course.
Yeah,
man.
It's like,
no,
we're not.
Yeah,
we are.
We just did an hour and a half.
It's crazy.
I went by so fast and I have a sandwich in the car.
I don't even need it.
I never go this far without eating 90 minute crazy.
Um,
yeah,
dude,
thank you so much for coming.
You are the best.
So Super Fun.
You guys are cute.
Thank you.
I know it's upsetting
that we did I do as good as Danny Brown.
No,
no,
no.
He was awesome.
Uh,
but you know,
you got thick skin so you're,
you know,
you're hilarious and I'm excited to your podcasting dude.
I think it's going to be really great for you.
Thanks man.
I really,
I really find it cathartic and it's like standup,
I started stand up as a hobby,
as an outlet.
And I feel like if I keep podcasting that watch dude,
you're going to,
in a year you're going to be like,
oh my God,
you're going to be turning down shit that like you,
you would just because you're like,
no,
my pod,
I can't step away from
doing other stuff but,
but,
but how many days or week are you in here?
One here,
one day.
One day,
a week and a half days a week.
Do you work on the podcast?
We usually do like,
I mean there's things that like the way that we do,
cause there's multi,
you know,
we have to find these farts.
So there's multimedia kind of things where we're,
we're always like sharing in a group videos,
topics,
airport.
You see a guy with no head write it down,
you send it to the blue band.
Take a picture or something stupid on we're,
we're building the show.
I worry that at the time I'm obsessing and enjoying this essentially this hobby,
like the podcast right now for me,
it's like I don't play golf,
so I'm enjoying this podcast.
Eventually it's a business and that's fine too.
But I go,
I probably could've done a special in those days that I was Po,
I probably could have written a movie instead.
So I'm still a little bit like,
oh,
should I be doing this?
Is this just a crazy,
you definitely should be doing this.
You definitely should be because the podcast we'll fund you can into your
material,
come up with premise is talking to people like,
oh,
that's good.
And then you'll write down,
oh,
I say,
yeah,
and it's gonna.
It's going to totally build into your ticket sales.
You're gonna end up doing your,
you know,
some show somewhere and then all these people are going to be the like,
Oh,
you love the bumping mix.
And they'll be like,
no,
no.
I'm here because of your podcast.
Like for sure.
Wow.
And you don't get squeamish about plugging it when you're on the road because
every comic has a podcast and you can feel for years.
I made jokes about how everyone has a podcast.
That's a joke that should be made.
It's an earned joke.
We all do.
But I mean,
if you're like,
if you enjoy doing it,
that's the thing I really truly do.
So like when you enjoy doing it,
it's,
you're having fun,
like your audience and your fans appreciate you doing something that they can
tell you actually like doing until this morning when I was like,
I want to do one this week.
And I had a text,
a couple of friends and I for,
for the beginning until now,
it was like friends and family kind of whoever was around that house.
And now I'm like,
hmm,
might be cool.
And I get a big star once in a while and then that's when I start to get really
like squeamish and they all want to do your podcast.
Everyone loves you.
Bruce Willis want to sit down,
fuck around with you ever roasted the one to sit down on my God.
Dude natural.
I got to pretend it's popular to get them on.
Actually no,
that's the thing is you can be like,
Hey,
I'm doing this.
I'm sure all of those people would be like,
yeah,
of course I still have a small but very loyal following like I feel like,
and then how much fun would it be?
Like I think if there's like a state,
like if there's a couple of standout roasts,
let's say,
you know,
cause you've roasted Trump,
you've roasted,
I don't know,
let's say whatever the bean burger sure get,
get together,
like flavor play or the people who worked on it with you.
Oh yeah.
You go like member like right up to Trump roast or Bieber roast and you guys re,
how do you think it's okay to make it a row centric thing?
Like if it's not about comedy,
but it's about more worldly issues,
wouldn't act being in a bigger audience.
But here's the thing,
because like who you are,
you can jump in and out of that.
You can do episodes where you're like talking about what's happening in North
Korea with a,
you know,
or you have Larry Charles and you're talking about this the,
and it's like not really about roasting and then you do your thing at the end.
Sure.
But like,
because you're who you are.
It's like,
what is,
she did well this week we're going to talk all about the Bieber Ross because you
know it got 25 million viewers.
It was this,
it was that,
and here's people that worked on as a fan,
how it'd be like,
oh,
that's an,
that's an awesome one off for this week.
The next week you don't have to do the same thing.
You can the next week you could.
You could have Dave on and talk about how you guys were just at the same,
it was just on.
He came by the house and that,
that alone is just fun.
The other part,
which I really love,
which I guess you have some of it after 10 years,
you're like,
whoa,
but I doing it in my house,
I having Larry Charles in my house was such a thrill.
Just just the excitement of that.
David tell like came by and I love Dave and just having Dave like sitting in my
podcast studio in my house smoking cigarettes and he mentioned his dad like it
was very open.
Like we just posted that episode.
It got tons of listens and I really do enjoy having people over.
So then there's a part of that of like the caterer,
his son in me that's like,
hey Larry,
do you want something to eat?
You want to bring a buddy?
You know?
I kind of really love that part.
Then you got to embrace that could be a part of the podcast,
the catering,
you know what I mean?
You can have a spread for people.
Yes.
Today's show is sponsored by touches potatoes and all the big bar Mitzvahs in
the 70s that just potatoes.
That by the way,
for people that want to do a deep dive on.
Jeff definitely listened to his,
uh,
Marin episode.
That was a great one.
Oh thanks.
I think I was his age,
his 800th episode or something.
It's a crazy one.
Yeah.
You know,
you haven't,
you know,
you never think people are going to be prepared.
And then you know,
mark,
I know my whole career and then he's like,
does this amazing interview and I'm like,
yeah.
Oh okay.
Yeah.
That's nice.
Yeah it's it you guys.
But one thing,
it was disappointing that whole episode,
no far eclipse at all.
One far corner.
You know,
like it was really kind of a downer.
Just talk about what you love on your show and we love you guys.
Keep it light and funny.
And that's kind of fun too.
Like sometimes I've been doing a thing called touchy subjects where I put in
like the most awkward,
you know Michael Jackson documentary,
bucked us woman,
a woman gets eaten by her own dog.
Like I like doing those kind of touchy subjects,
what I call where we're not even talking about comedy and it's nothing.
You'll find out a lot of audiences love segments.
So you bring up touchy subjects and then there's a hot gas coming on.
Dude,
believe me,
the,
your fan base is listening.
Like I can't wait until we get to touchy subject for sure.
Didn't roast and peace at the end.
You get the death,
they want to do one it they want it had a good drug the other day about Peter
Torque from the monkeys.
You know,
he guide and I was a big fan and you know the monkey's revolutionized music
unless you've ever heard of the Beatles,
the stones,
pink Floyd,
imagine dragons,
Nelly.
Yeah.
It's fun dealing with like the sad stuff.
It is Cathartic.
I always,
yeah,
I agree.
And you have to come from a little tragedy to appreciate it to him.
Michael Jackson jokes.
Do you have any great ones?
Oh boy.
Did you roast him when he died?
I feel like you would be the master at,
I had a bunch of Michael Jackson jokes when he died.
It was like already 10 years,
right?
Yeah.
Isn't it crazy how it's come back around?
It's how like there was a time where we had like a Michael Jackson,
you know,
kid fucking joke or something.
Right.
And then if you were to hear that joke a few years ago,
you'd be like,
okay.
And now it's like refreshed,
like,
yeah.
Really because of the environment we're in.
And you know,
I watched it and it was a very painful show to watch and I do it,
but I only came twice.
It's hard to hold it in that whole time for so much better.
What the Fart or the Michael Jackson.
What was a bigger man?
So download rev rate,
review and subscribe.
Thick skin with Jeff Ross,
with Jeff Ross,
Spotify,
apple will chin.
I don't know.
I just signed up for all of them.
You should do Google play.
It's everywhere.
I don't have Google play.
I don't think you got to get on Google play.
What are you doing man?
Androids out there.
Okay.
Um,
watch pumping my,
watch it on Netflix.
Keep your eyes peeled for the new dates.
He's going to be touring with date with his Nana David towl.
Yeah,
we just put up the first two and then to where we started.
Great.
Out in Pennsylvania to do and I'm doing that next month.
That's a great place.
Yeah,
I did it.
Lance,
Bethlehem.
I love that place.
For some reason,
Dave and I always upgrade shows.
Yeah.
Flam Borgata,
which of course there's a layup for us.
That's where I'm from the area and I love it.
My family always comes.
I love that you,
you're the opposite of a lot of comics in that sense too,
where all these shows you're at,
you're like,
oh,
it's so great.
I can see so much family show up with like 30 people that like all crazy because
I'll have 25 people eating Pastrami and my green room and Dave will be alone
right across the hall.
And that green room smoking,
that's me talking to the stage manager lets me about who was there last week and
why they didn't sell out,
which is negative.
And then Dave eventually will stick his head in and you know,
we'll always go out afterwards.
You know,
it's kind of fun where he's so negative and I'm so positive.
And then we meet somewhere in the middle.
It's hilarious.
It's a great dynamic man.
You guys are supportive and thanks for inviting me on your podcast.
What a treat,
all the advice and all the advice on podcasts,
please.
And I gave you,
gave you guys some,
some roasting advice.
A lot of it utilizing it.
You're a,
your next gig.
Minneapolis,
tits.
April four through six acme comedy club.
That's supposed to be a great spot.
It's amazing.
I'm so excited to finally go there.
I haven't been there yet,
but I lost my virginity to somebody who lives near there.
The great Lewis Lee
17 but it didn't have an older gent.
What do you want them to be?
I wasn't ready.
What?
How old was she?
She was just saying it was Christmas Eve.
Christmas Eve when I was in high school.
17 maybe.
She was 18 and I was seven.
I was 17 I fucking destroyed this girl.
That's okay.
I mean it was pound town.
She stop and maybe a hundred pounds.
I was two 45 yeah.
Is this your Dalmatian girlfriend?
This girl,
she barely spoke English.
She was my God exchange student.
Costa Rica.
Oh,
stop.
It was weird if she spoke English until you fucked her
brains.
Do you still talk to your first love makings?
No.
I did see her when I was in did a show in Minnesota.
Oh a while back.
She came to the show and I brought her on stage and we both sat Indian style on
the stage and told the story,
which was really fun.
It was beautiful.
You're going to have a great memorial men when you go,
it's going to be something better than Brody's I think so.
It was really hard.
You know Bradley Cooper was there.
Dude,
I know.
That was pretty big deal.
Phillips.
Ron White.
That was crazy.
It was crazy.
No,
I think you're going to have a great outpouring of love.
Yeah.
You got a lot of friends who said you're positive.
You invite people to your home.
Tom and I never do that out of our house,
but like we got this because we were like,
yeah,
I have stop having people over at the house.
We have two small children.
I understand that.
What are they doing right now looking for fart videos,
like child labor?
Probably.
Well,
I just taught our three year old to say I took a dump and well,
I'm like,
I've kind of,
it's funny,
but it's like he's saying it and I'm picturing him,
you know,
with other teachers and parents and he's like,
I got a dump.
And I'm like,
all right,
damn isn't a bad word.
What is it?
Fine.
Maybe there's other things he can learn first.
Like what?
Like I love you mommy.
He's,
he says we've got to me first thing he said,
yeah,
he says other stuff,
but I like take it down.
I just think it's funny.
Yeah,
it's funny.
Dumping is great.
I'm actually,
it's funny,
like last thing,
like,
you know,
talking about when we're talking about my jail shows and roasting and working on
the border and doing stuff that has heart and maybe some meaning and a mission
to it.
And then I've been working out jokes locally and they're all about shitting and
farting and dogs and it's like,
it's like I this crazy journey just to go right back to the first act I ever
did.
Of course.
Yeah.
It really all comes back.
It really is.
It gave me the license.
We've always just talking about how much we would love that.
I'm Carlin,
who was,
you know,
such a brilliant guy.
And we'd dive into these topics and break it down and you would just be so blown
away by his intellect.
And then after one of those incredibly well constructed bits,
it would be fart jokes and then you'd go back to something.
It's so loud.
You know who hates forced the most midgets they live when I site
Buddy Hackett roast and peace.
All right,
Jeff Ross.
Thank you sir.
Hundred plus minutes.
Nina.
Thank you both.
Thanks.
Twi.
Mh Hood Snack by falling water.
Sound closing song.
This mother fucker.
Damn motherfucker.
This motherfucker,
this motherfucker,
this motherfucker Burrito
bagger Doritos and
beef steaks.
Beef steak,
cheese,
cheese.
Beat
my ass,
my ass home.